[Music]
south from the empire state building if
you go about 20 blocks you're going to
find yourself in an area of new york
city known in the early 1900s is book
row
and one of the survivors of that era is
the strand bookstore which is now
located here at 12th and broadway in
greenwich village today book tv presents
a special edition of in-depth live from
the strand and we begin outside with
nancy bass who runs this store along
with her father fred
and who's the original owner of this
store was your grandfather yes ben bath
in 1927.
how do you characterize this store
this is the greatest place on earth
it has every kind of book in it every
subject area
types of books we have new books we have
rare books we have used books i think
it's heaven how much how many books
we have over two and a half million we
think close to three million we haven't
quite done a count yet but we know that
we have we have we had eight miles of
books
now we've changed it to 18 miles of
books 18 miles of books well our viewers
will see some of those today and we're
going to be talking a lot about
political books and you don't even have
to go inside the store to find that the
strand is a store where you obviously
have political customers yes
what's going on with the industry right
now and with bookstores as you're
selling these political books this
proliferation of political books i've
never seen so many political books i
think that the whole villages and
america is really charged about about
what's going on
there's just uh
on every subject everybody's got a
political book out is there uh are there
more political books on your own
bestseller list than normal absolutely
what do you know some of them that um
well bushwacked is probably our best
seller right now and the 911 commission
report we can't keep enough copies down
the book wrote which we talked about at
the beginning what was it and where was
it it was located um just around the
corner from us on fourth avenue and it
was an area that was um
prevalent in the 1850s and it ran to
about the 70s and along this area which
was from which was fourth avenue from
14th street to aster place at its height
there were 48 bookstores and my
grandfather's bookstore was amongst them
tell me about your grandfather my
grandfather was an intellectual he loved
books he lived for books he
did some writing he was reading
constantly he loved culture
it was um he collected books of course
why did he call this place the strand it
was it was named after
the publishing district in england
which um and also the strand magazine
which was uh arthur conan doyle had so
how do you get involved how do i get
involved how did you get involved um i
think just being in this family i think
it's in my blood i think i've always
just wanted to do this
when you when you decided to come a part
of this you um
you said that you were going to to do a
lot of different things but you also
said something that was interesting as
you were quoted as saying that the
strand is neither has neither tried nor
won any good housekeeping awards
should we show our viewers
we'll show our viewers a little bit
about that we're going in the strand now
lots of security why um we just it's
like a labyrinth here it's just there's
so many little cubby holes and people
also don't we don't have a lot of space
so people can leave their bags and shop
without being unhindered
well i want to stop first right here at
the fiction and non-fiction reviewers
cop
what is a reviewer's copy well this is
one of the things that strand is known
for and being in the publishing
center of
of of america in new york we're able to
get something called reviewers copies
these are new books that are sent out to
reviewers like the um media like the new
york times and ahead of ahead of when
they come out ahead of them yes um and
it's there we characterize them as books
that are published this year and last
year and we sell them for half of what
the chains sell them for do you sell
them before they're published
before they go on the market a lot of
times yeah that's pretty common so it's
people that are in the know they we have
the review books downstairs in our
underground
well i want to show this one
particularly because it's one that is
getting a lot of attention right now in
the political season
paul alexander's book the candidate now
if i were paul alexander would i be
happy that the strands price is 11.97
even though the list price is almost 24
dollars i think if i if i was an author
i would want everyone to read my book
and i would want everyone to tell all
their friends how great the book is and
that they should pick up a copy now who
how do you get these reviewer copies oh
they're they're sent to us um will we
buy them we um the
we buy them from the media um
media people come in here and sell their
reviewers yes they do or we even do they
mail it to us from all over the country
and is this a money maker for you yes it
is
it's a great thing for the customers to
buy and to have new books at half price
is a real opportunity when did the store
open today
it on sunday it opens at 11 o'clock so
we're open seven days till 10 30 at
night so it's been it's been open for
about an hour now i want to stop next at
this new york section
uh a good section for you i mean do
people come in here to find books about
new york yes it's probably the most
popular section i love reading books
like new york too you had mentioned it i
love being here you had mentioned that
this was a bestseller for you right now
yes what uh do these kinds of books sell
better at this time when we're just one
week before the anniversary of 9 11.
i think that tourists will buy it i
think that people that that live in the
village and have been through this
have had
so much 911 that maybe they're a little
burnt out about it really but i think i
think people love to read books about
the history of new york i think that's
that's kind of a never anything the
architecture about new york um
and um
there's always coming out with with new
kind of books like gotham and books
about central park and um
manhattan unfurled so popular well there
are several different ones here but
let's go ahead i want to show our
viewers
this place which is the manager's picks
yes what happens that's a special table
here these are these are recommended
books from our managers who have worked
here for
for years and and know the books and um
these are books that they that they
think that that customers would love to
read and that they love reading and show
me this book why is the book like this
important for the strand this is um this
book is called the cabinet of natural
curiosity and it's just this fun book
oversized filled with
heavily illustrated big color plates and
i people just love it having it on their
table and to look through it and it's
just
a good number of these books yes we do
and it's been um it's been a consistent
seller
let's go back over here to your best
seller list and
what we do is we get back into politics
yeah and the best sellers
so these are strand best sellers and you
see it's all political
a lot of a lot of books about bush how
is bill clinton's book selling it sells
very very very well
we'll take a look at some of those and
i've read part of it too
and then i want to ask you about this
section
if you look over here there is the
underground now how many floors of the
strand we now have four floors okay so
what is the underground the underground
has has the review copies that we've
talked about and has a lot of other
great sections like americana and it has
medical section and business and it has
the kids section right now but we're
going to move it move it upstairs to our
new space that we've just opened now did
you did i hear you threatened to have
your employees yesterday that they had
to get the downstairs cleaned up every
yes even though we're not going
downstairs yes
because we have so many boxes and books
everywhere we are just bursting out with
books
books by the yard or books by the foot
what is it um it's it's something that
that i thought of that i sell to um
to individuals or to stores and i put
together libraries for people so does do
they care what's in the books
um usually they do if it's um if it's
for somebody's home you know i do a lot
of homes out in the hamptons and i do a
lot of very high-end new york apartments
usually though i try to find out as much
i try to survey the owners of these
apartments and try to find out as much
as i can about what they like and try to
be very thoughtful about my picks for it
so i can put together an exceptional
library then we have
stores and you know um
hotels and and other
places where it's not the content's not
that important and i our cheapest books
are ten dollars a foot and our most
expensive would be antique leather for
350
a foot now if somebody has seen the
sopranos where have they seen your work
they've they've seen it in back of the
psychiatrist's office all the textbooks
yes yes that's right and if they've
watched sex in the city where they have
they see they've seen it everywhere
they've seen it mr biggs they've seen it
um brishnakov's place and carrie's
apartment everywhere who's the most
exciting client that you've ever had
here for you the um the most exciting
library i did was a believe it or not
somebody has a 35 room apartment in new
york and i have done and they have books
in every single room so i've personally
figured out what would be the best books
for every room and there was some rooms
that were appropriate for antique
leather and then there was a family
media room so i was able to put a lot of
books on film and then they had children
so i was able to put books that were
appropriate for the children that's been
my most exciting project when was
michael jackson here michael jackson was
here a year ago and i opened up the
store for him in his big entourage all
of his kids came all the nannies came
all the security came so we opened it up
after 10 30 at night and we started up
in the rare book room and he he's a big
lover of books what'd he buy um he
bought a lot of art books a lot of
photography he wanted ron doll
children's books first edition books
books about black music books about
versailles
it was really fun it was really electric
for him to be here we're going to meet
your father in a little while he's going
to tell us a little bit about some of
the writers who come in here but thank
you very much appreciate it we have a
sign over here that
nancy bass has put up announcing the
c-span is going to be at the strand
today as you can see we have art
spiegelman coming up harold evans
richard brookheiser nicholas baz baines
adam bellow peter osnos matt hendoff
john fund and amy goodman all that
coming up in the next four hours so
we're on the first floor now and we're
going to take you up to the second floor
this is i understand the first time that
people have visited the second floor
because it has just been newly renovated
so we take you up and brian land is with
our first guest there
connie thanks we have a lot of
discussion ready for you this afternoon
we want to get right to it adam bello
and peter osnos are both new yorkers
they've lived here for a very long time
they've written books and soul books and
let me start with adam bellow on the
political side of this how would you
describe when you've got the the top of
the new york times bestseller list the
first two are
basically republican books the second
two are democratic books what's the
state of the book publishing world
related to politics right now well we're
in the middle of a of a very uh
highly partisan contested election uh
and so it's natural for political books
to be uh to be in the fore um
publishers know that political books
come around every four years we try to
avoid publishing political books in in
off years um but everybody uh always has
a list of books that they that they're
in a rush to get out before the election
and of course then the question is
what's the best time uh how do you how
do you uh space your books how do you
avoid uh going head-to-head with uh with
an overwhelming competitor uh for
example everybody wanted to stay out of
the way of bill clinton's book um uh and
uh and for another example uh david
brooks uh the author of bobo's in
paradise brought out a book this year uh
that was not specifically political and
i think it suffered for that
everybody wanted to stay out of the way
of bill clinton's book who's everybody
uh other publishers people who have
other books that they want to publicize
and uh to get to get attention for
because you have to have attention from
the media if you're going to to uh
publish successfully a political book
peter asks knows anything unusual in the
political book sales issue
well i think the intensity as adam says
is is extraordinary more than other
years i think so i think there's always
been uh you know political books
published certainly all the time and
particularly in election years but what
we're seeing is a velocity
and a shrillness
uh that is extraordinary i mean the
degree to which so many of these books
on the left and on the right are attack
books i think that's different when we
talk about political books you're
talking about a spectrum that could be
books of great seriousness and depth and
purpose or you can talk about books
which are just polemics well all this
started years ago with
something called common sense which was
rather
people thought it was an attack book is
there anything wrong with attack books
let me go back to adam bellow well you
know you're right to bring up tom payne
and i think the way we have to view the
current uh crop of political books is
that they're really pamphlets uh this is
a genre of of
um political discourse that is very high
on invective
uh it's it's not uh often uh based on on
reason and evidence it doesn't appeal to
the better nature it appeals to the
passions uh it uh it tries to you know
whip up political support on on one side
it doesn't try very much very hard to
persuade the opposition uh and that's i
think the definition of a political
pamphlet only it's just the case now
that they're being published in
hardcover at you know 26 dollars you
have a soft cover book there's coming
out when tomorrow it's official
publication date is tomorrow and this is
in a sense the ultimate political book
what is it it is the book written uh
by carrie and edwards and it is their
political plan our plan for america
stronger at home respected in the world
it is the
program that they intend to put into
place should they be elected that could
hardly be more political
art spiegelman who is well known in this
part of the world is going to be here in
about an hour and he has a new book
called in the shadows of no towers
and what i'm looking for here is a
statement he makes about political
parties
up front he calls it the ostrich party
uh we can show the audience what this
looks like as i read it
uh ostrich party join your fellow
americans before it's too late rise up
and stick your heads in the ground and
up here he says ramiji rampaging uh
republican elephants dim-witted
democratic donkeys no wonder americans
don't bother to vote the two-party
animals are both 19th century dinosaurs
interested only in their own survival
not ours we need a third party that
actually represents us a new and
revolutionary ostrich party reaction
from
mr bella
well
uh
i i would only say that the i think the
two parties are 20th century dinosaurs
um uh we got rid of the 19th century
parties uh during the depression and new
deal
but i think essentially that's it's true
that both parties are essentially uh
organized around uh
cold war themes and
uh outdated coalitions uh and uh there
is a undoubtedly a growing number of
people who describe themselves as
independents
um certainly uh you know when i when i
started out uh in publishing uh there
wasn't any such thing you were either on
the left or on the right uh i see a real
difference today i think there are many
many more people who who would gravitate
towards a more centrist party david
brooks had a very interesting article in
the new york times sunday magazine
last weekend about this calling for a
progressive conservatism uh of a kind
that might appeal to liberal republicans
and conservative democrats i think that
would be very attractive peter asking us
janet brown who is the executive
director of the presidential debate
commission was on c-span this morning
and a number of the callers were upset
saying there's nobody on your board from
the independent world there are both
republicans and democrats you're not
going to let an independent get involved
in this debate in any way here you have
somebody who's really upset that says
third parties are the answer but yet the
system doesn't make it easy for a third
party to get into this
well i mean obviously that's a that's a
fair comment it uh the truth is that if
people wanted to vote independent they
certainly can i think that there's
nothing that stops the great majority of
the people in this country vote for the
two parties i mean the overwhelming
majority they have over and over and
over again and we've seen
efforts to start third parties or
independent candidacies and then the
truth is when the election gets very
close in most cases
people end up voting for one of the
other parties what are some of the other
books you have coming out right about
now that would be political well i you
know i think i thought you would ask me
that question brian but i want to start
by apologizing to all of the public
affairs authors who are not included in
this list and to say that it's not a
deliberate oversight uh i brought a
couple
one is again a book which
i think is particularly entertaining for
anybody interested in politics we got
this idea a couple of years ago there
are people in american life
who are powers and then there are people
in american life who are politicians
uh jack beatty senior editor at the
atlantic wrote a wonderful biography of
james michael curley the
former mayor of uh boston who ran for
his uh mayoralty from jail
he was apollo
mayor richard daley chicago he was
apollo lyndon johnson he was a power
uh ed koch rudy giuliani pals new york
piles so what we wanted to do in this
political season was to get the best
writing that we could get over the years
about pals we wanted to redefine what it
is for americans who live in today's
world
about
older fellow politicians of another age
mostly
um
and how they express themselves and
that's what jack did it's a beautifully
sort of well-balanced way of seeing
how the pow operates we have a lot of
people you're going to meet in this room
before the afternoon's over richard
brookheiser and harold evans john fun
amy goodman art spiegelman but we also
and i get the sense just listening to
the murmur out there in the audience we
have one of those wonderful new york
crowds that has a lot they have a lot of
opinions sitting right out there and i
want you to get into this
very quickly if you have either an
opinion or a question you'd like to ask
one of the things that drives me crazy
about moderators after they moderate one
of these things they always say that you
can get up ask a question you're not
allowed to give your opinion after
people here have been giving their
opinions for hours on end so you're
allowed to give your opinion here if
you'd like to today and if somebody has
a question or comment about what we're
talking about we're gonna get to you in
just another two or three minutes so get
up to the microphone please and we'll
get you involved in this and anybody
watching live come on down and join us
there's some
room not much but some room here on the
second floor of the strand bookstore
adam bellow you start off an article
this week in new york magazine talking
about your daughter lily who you just
happen to have with you here today what
was that about
i i was asked
to write an article for new york
magazine's uh special convention issue
about what it is like
to be a conservative
in a city a new york and in a profession
publishing that are known for their
liberalism and so i wrote a i wrote a
brief essay bought a biographical essay
explaining how uh how it could possibly
have come about that somebody like
myself who grew up
on the upper west side
uh in the heart of uh of the liberal
counter culture
someone who was a child of the 60s
uh who had shared all the the the
attitudes and and uh ideas of of that
generation how you know how could it
possibly have happened that somebody
like that could go to the other side
could become a you know one of them
and uh so i so i wrote it uh an article
explaining how how that process came
about gradually through uh largely
through my my sense of the
um the changes in
the liberal intelligence my feeling that
uh that it had become uh less open to
ideas more anti-intellectual in in a way
so how does lily get into this well my
my daughter is now 17 years old she's a
she's a senior at fieldston and
throughout her childhood i never
i never wanted to impose my my political
views on her i certainly wanted to um to
feel that she had to take my part in in
any political arguments at school
and and yet after i published a book
last year
uh of my own uh on nepotism uh it became
common you know common knowledge uh in
her in her peer group that her father
was a was a well-known neoconservative
editor and so she she finally came to me
and she said you know is this true are
you really
are you really a republican you know is
it
what is and what does that mean
and so i i carefully explained to her
that what the difference in my view is
between a republican which i i'm not and
a conservative
which is how i describe myself we're
more more technically a neo-conservative
and this is a distinction that many
liberals don't don't recognize it's not
their it's not their fault it's natural
for them to think that that anyone who's
a conservative
uh
would naturally be a republican party
member but this was something that i i
felt that was a serious question it was
part of her political education and so i
i tried to answer that question peter
osnos we know if you came to manhattan
if you were a liberal where you would
live where would you live comfortably if
you were a conservative upper east side
i think there's still a lot of room for
conservatives on the upper side certain
kinds of conservatives like to prefer
what
the outer boroughs i guess staten island
queens
i don't think the upper west side is
where a uh a
neoconservative necessarily or
conservative would choose to live
probably
how there was an article in new york
times this week how much of this started
with lars limbaugh's successful
hardcover two and a half million sales
book that changed everything when it
came to publishing you mean how much of
the sort of surge of political oh of
conservative books conservative books
yeah well but you know god man at yale
was published a long time ago ago
william buckley conscience of a
conservative there have been a is a very
distinguished tradition of conservative
authors in america and have been writing
them and publishing them and people have
been reading them by the tens and tens
of millions over the years so i don't
think you know we have a tendency to
rediscover things i think the thing
about limbaugh that's distinctive
is that he uh came along at the age of
talk radio the internet the blog the
sort of the
very very deeply rooted ideological
differences that are now
able to be heard with megaphones that's
what's i think changed the degree to
which the debate goes on at at that at
shout level is much
more i think apparent than it was i mean
they've always been talk really remember
father coughlin in the 30s was a
preacher in detroit who
who had a very strong constituency for a
very very tough right-wing
message i think that some things have
always existed but everything now has
been been risen up
by the level of uh to which things are
available
this idea to come to strand bookstore
was nancy bass's idea a long time ago
and we figured because we had so many of
our crew up here that they would just
love to stay a couple more days after
the conventions uh if you see them
standing around the room if they look
exhausted to you
it's just a myth uh they've only been
working non-stop for this entire summer
through these conventions uh and if
anybody deserves credit for for what we
do at c-span they do we're going to go
to the phones but we also want to go to
the audience anybody in the audience
right now have something they want to
say about publishing and whether or not
conservatives are getting a raw deal or
whether or not you like the the uh the
way the publishing business is going if
uh there is anybody please step up to
the microphone right now when can you go
to back to the microphone and we'll get
right to you and we'll also get the
callers involved the numbers will be on
the screen and because this is the
political season we're going to split
these lines up as we always do
president bush versus john kerry and
others and those of you who use that
other line should not be planning to
vote for either john kerry or president
bush go ahead and begin dying right now
let me ask adam bellow whether or not a
conservative
in this town has a chance in the
publishing world
oh uh absolutely um of course
things are much different today than
they were when i started out in
publishing which is in the late 80s
i think
peter's correct to say that that
conservative publishing predates the
limbaugh era um uh i became aware
of uh the uh
the drama of publishing what i think of
as dangerous books um
uh dangerous that is to the to the to
the majority liberal world view of the
of the media and academic establishment
when alan bloom's book was published the
closing of the american mind which came
out in 1987
um or 86 and that really i think i
always think of as the beginning of the
phase of the culture war um in which a
series of quite serious book uh books
were published by conservative authors
that opened up a channel
in
in the distribution and
sale of books
these were books that had to be taken
seriously by reviewers
subsequently i feel that
um we entered a new phase in which uh
the people who are publishing books from
the conservative side are not
intellectuals not what i would describe
as intellectuals i i confess that i'm an
intellectual snob and i have a uh i have
a preference for for people who actually
know something uh and moreover who are
who are intent on persuading
uh a fair-minded opponent rather than
someone who's whose uh hope is simply to
whip up the the political base adam
bella lives in new york city and peter
ostense lives in greenwich connecticut
although he grew up here in this town
born in bombay india adam bellow is an
executive editor at large for four years
now with double day publishing and he
spent four or five years with as
editorial director of the pre-press
which was a part of simon schuster and
how old is public affairs now public
affairs was founded in 1997 so we're in
our eighth year and how many years with
the washington post i spent 18 years
with the washington post and uh 12 years
at random house as an editor and
publisher
let's go to our first comment or
question from our audience give us your
name please and tell us what you want to
tell it and i live in queens
and uh i do not sleep at night so i'm
listening to radio programs almost all
night long
and though i'm not a conservative i've
always respected uh people like buckley
and i watch john mclaughlin but the
radio programs that are supposed to be
conservative are so filled
with
with vitriolic statements and hatred and
i feel that i'm not when i listen to
them because i'm not a conservative
that i must be un-american and this has
also filtered into the republican
campaign
and i think that this is so very
disturbing and many people are disturbed
and they don't know how to express
themselves or where to express
themselves so that's what i let me ask
you a question about uh yes air america
do you listen to any of our america well
it happens that i don't know the pro i
don't i wanted to listen to air america
but i don't know the channel believe it
or not i know that when this is very
strange but when al franken was told you
know i said well where can i find air
america so i've been i've been sir you
know surfing the dials and i get abc and
i get wor on uh during the night
and and and i do hear uh a few were
liberal concer liberal speakers too but
the hate is not there like it is in the
conservatives that's my feeling let me
just offer this i listened to it coming
up here on xm radio uh america and uh i
think uh you'd be
surprised some of the language being
used the president calling the president
united states a liar and all that is
strong language and i think you'd be
surprised if you hear america they seem
to be taking up the same
way of doing things that the other side
does i would ask you peter oscars have
you heard any of it yeah um and yes it
it you know it's it's forged in a
tradition of polemic and it is can be
can be very very harsh anything i think
that well i i think you're
you're with all the respect ryan you're
slightly adding to the problem here the
truth is that there are there's a vast
arena of place where people are not
shouting at each other and where it
isn't all about people being a liar i
think the amazing thing about the time
that we that we now live is that so much
more information is available and people
have the the opportunity if they want to
the difference is
that years ago essentially other people
were gatekeepers uh if you listen to
television you listen to three networks
and maybe one or two local stations
every one of us now is an
editor-in-chief we we
have both the chance the obligation the
responsibility to make our choices of
what if if somebody wants to listen
to you know michael savage which is
breathtaking uh go ahead and do it but
you don't have to listen to michael
savage because there's a whole lot of
other stuff on there that you can listen
to and i think that's an important
distinction you want to add to that
annabelle well i i i think peter is
right i think the the problem is partly
in them i think largely in the media
themselves because uh the media really
are media of entertainment
more often than not and what plays in
the media are extreme
uh statements and views what i find as a
publisher of uh books that i i consider
to be serious and solid and
intellectually respectable is that it's
very difficult to get a hearing
for a book that doesn't take an extreme
position one way or the other because it
just doesn't play well as entertainment
let's take a call from aptos california
aptos california you're on the air
please go ahead well thank you very much
uh i appreciate your program as always
and it's always very enlightening uh i
just wanted to say that i think that
probably
uh uh print wise i think one of the the
biggest injustices to the united states
right now in america is
is the fact that the the liberal press
has is just absolutely
out of control i mean they they
they say things and do things that that
are just so blatantly biased
and yet they won't admit it i've
canceled two
subscriptions to a couple of magazines
of the periodicals that used to be
considered mainstream simply because of
the fact they won't even admit that they
are liberal they don't even admit that
they're left leaning
i think i think freedom of the press is
is no longer there
according to the liberal media simply
because of the fact that they no longer
as as newspaper would like people would
like to say
present the news now they present their
views of the news
and and isn't it ironic that
how bad iraq has gone since the embedded
news journalists have left and it's left
to the talking heads to tell us what's
going on in iraq all right afterwards
thank you let me let's come back to
books
why is it that the public and it calls
the archon show upset about the
so-called liberal media
but books has very strong views and no
one calls up and says those books
shouldn't be allowed to say what they
say
well i think they're first of all the
wonderful thing about books is that we
have survived
uh 500 years or more since the printing
press you know it isn't 10 years ago
that people said the book was really a
dinosaur we were finished everybody was
going to go to e-books everybody was
going to have a whole different way of
getting material and here we are
this year in particular political debate
centers around books i i think for
example the fact that two million people
have bought the 911 commission report
for 10 bucks is an amazing fact about
where our society is today and what's
equally amazing about it is they could
have gotten it for free by downloading
it and some 5 million did i downloaded
it yeah i didn't realize was that many
and that's terrific i mean people are
making their choices about information i
think this is the point i
would choose to drive home
that if if the caller wants to cancel
subscriptions he has the right to do
that but there are a lot of magazines
that the caller could be reading and
there are a lot of books that you can
read the truth of the matter is in our
world we our i think society is one of
the first in history that actually has a
problem with excess we have so much of
everything the hardest things for us to
do is choose
and uh what a great opportunity that is
let me grab a call and we'll get adam
bell into this cincinnati ohio you're on
the air please go ahead
how you doing um my question is for um
adam adam bellow
uh because you
you said you're a neo-conservative and
i happen to be a liberal um
living in the very opposite situation of
you in new york because i live in
cincinnati which is something like
90 percent
uh republican
so i'm i'm in a minority and
i'm surrounded by evangelical christians
which
um many people in the country think that
is
a situation that's basically
in the south
and
cincinnati is a northern state that is
pretty much evangelical and
my fear is that
the
evangelicals have infiltrated somehow
maybe it's happened very slowly since
the 60s
probably i guess with um
since the 60s i think somehow slowly
there's been sort of some some kind of
revolt because civil people uh
aren't
thrilled with civil rights for some
reason and um
since then i'm gonna let you go i think
that you've made enough points there
that adam billow can respond
well
um
i wouldn't want to be surrounded by
evangelical christians either which is
why i live in new york not in cincinnati
um
uh
i you know i sympathize and no one wants
to be surrounded um by anybody uh who
they feel is is alien and hostile to
them
um of course it's true that since since
the 80s uh particularly evangelical
christians have become more
more vocal and better organized and uh
my my feeling about that was as an
editor was simply that i wanted to to
get their views out uh and to get them
engaged in the debate it seemed to me
the the best way
of moderating those those uh illiberal
impulses that they they sometimes
express is to engage them in the
political process and to and give them a
hearing because i think they were right
to complain
about the secularization of the society
and the the the low regard in which
religious people and religion itself is
held if you've just joined us we are
live uh in the midday on sunday at the
strand bookstore
which is the largest uh used bookstore i
guess in the country some two over two
million nancy bass can
not up and down if she can hear me back
there uh there's another big one out on
the west coast pals that we've been to
before they're opening up a brand new
floor here
in a town that has finally cooled off a
little bit even though there's very
little air conditioning at the strand
which they're known for over the years
not having air conditioning but uh come
on up join us if you'd like and if
anybody in the audience has a comment or
question they want to make about the
discussion come on up to the microphone
and we will then take another call go
ahead please give us your name hi i'm
lara uh my question is like uh how do
editors like your personal politics get
involved in choosing the books like like
a concert like if it's a conservative or
a liberal book like um do you even
attempt a balance or like do do the pup
do the publishers really just choose
mostly like if they're a conservative
band they they would like
produce more conservative books peter
osnos what about your company
well i i would like to say i'd like to
believe that we're the kind of place
that could publish anybody's book if it
was the kind of book that really made
sense if we felt there was an argument
we publish after all brian lamb's books
i mean talk about going on a limb uh
tough decision we uh uh look i i would
say that if you look into any public
affairs book and look in the back of it
you will see a dedication page
that was my privilege as the founder of
this company to choose people to whom
the company would be dedicated they
happened to be the people i'd worked for
over the years one of them was the
chairman of random house and the founder
of human rights watch robert l bernstein
another one was ben bradley at the
washington post who after all led the
post coverage of watergate pentagon
papers and so forth and the third one is
is he stone izzy stone was a great
radical
uh pamphleteer in the tradition of tom
payne there are a lot of people in this
country saying he was a radical leftist
i know izzy stone was a shopkeeper he
ran a little company and he sold his
newsletter at five bucks a pop and
that's what in the jeffersonian to the
soles of his feet so that's the kind of
tradition that i think public affairs
tries to represent and i would hate for
anybody to say that we would only
publish a book if i or any one of the
editors agreed with it
but some of these conservative polemics
that you say plummets come through the
door are you going to publish them if
sure absolutely if it if somebody came
to us with a book that was well let me
show you something if you've got a
second here the sharansky book if we
don't want to send all this stuff
toppling down this is a book we're
publishing this for this is actually a
bound uh
i i knew nathan sharansky
when he was a young dissident in russia
and i was a young reporter for the
washington post i published his uh
prison book fear no evil since those
years in russia now he lives in israel
where he's been in the government people
say that you know sharansky was a great
inspiration to us now he's a right
winger
and what i wanted to hear was what he
felt about the issues of freedom and
democracy and so on this is a book that
isn't about left and right in my very
very very very deeply held view this is
a book about right and wrong and it is
going to appeal i suppose to
conservatives and a lot of people who
are liberal will say they're offended
but it's a book worth reading adam
bellow do publishers and editors at
publishing houses here in this town make
decisions based on
political persuasion they make decisions
based on taste uh and preference which
in my view is often a uh
a kind of disguised uh form of ideology
people tend to sublimate their ideology
in in their aesthetic judgment
so they'll say something that is in bad
taste when they mean it's bad politics
there's no question that uh that people
publish books that they care about that
they're passionate about that they
believe in and if you have a publishing
industry in which most people are
liberals you're just not going to have
too many conservative books being
published the people who did break down
those barriers and prove that you could
make money publishing conservative books
were in fact committed conservatives
like people like my my old boss and
mentor the late irwin glickas people
like judith regan
people like bill shinker who published
dan quayle
these are people who really believed
that conservatives had something
important to say
art spiegelman will be here in about 20
minutes and most of you will know him
from the complete mouse
this is a
a he's a pulitzer prize winner he'll be
here to talk about his new book which is
about the twin towers and he will um
address this audience for a while then
take some calls from audience and also
some questions from the audience we hope
you'll stay with us we go to bridgton
new jersey you're on the air go ahead
please
very much brian for taking my call um my
question is i've noticed that there is a
proliferation of
um conservative books now it seems like
it's almost like every publisher has to
you know we've got to get a conservative
book out there just to make some money
and
in just
browsing through a bookstore it seems to
me a lot of these books frankly just
aren't very interesting and i guess my
question is
how do you determine
something is going to sell well versus
you know let's just balance out the
playing field so to speak to have all
these conservative books out there good
question thanks peter
well you know book buying is a is a is a
daily referendum
and if people want to read a book and
buy it i think publishers will needless
to say do them
uh if you publish a book or conservative
books don't i think what's interesting
in the last couple of years every major
i believe every major publisher
the big conglomerates have added
explicitly conservative imprints
and that's certainly true at
random house and i think it's true at
penguin and they wouldn't be doing that
if they didn't think it was a worthwhile
thing to do and they're not they're not
doing it i i don't believe at a
particular political conviction i think
they're doing because those books sell i
mean ours is a market-driven society
things sell people will do them if they
don't sell they'll be forgotten very
quickly
well of course that's true that's the
same same reason why time warner uh put
out uh uh uh uh you know rap music by
two live crew and they were they were
attacked for it and they said well look
this is what people want um we don't
necessarily like it uh but it uh it
sells it makes money and that's that's i
think that's absolutely the case after
once it was demonstrated that there was
a large market for conservative books
one that didn't exist before a market
that was created
largely during the clinton years um by
houses like regnery on the one hand the
more extreme end more partisan end and
the free press on the other
then publishers woke up and they
realized well there is there's this new
market and we we don't want to be uh
shut out of it
a case is also being made we'll go to
this question a moment the tour of duty
by doug brinkley has changed the whole
discussion
in this race because he brought up the
whole vietnam swift boat story that made
a bunch of them mad they all got
together published another book i think
that gives it gives a
book a lot of credit i think the truth
is that that this has been a big issue
uh you know vietnam is is an unresolved
question in the minds of a great many
americans i think kerry led with his
chin on this one his considerable chin
and the truth is that it's a battle that
he's now engaged in and and i think he
feels he's on very strong ground yes sir
your name please my name is richard uh
there are three things that matter to me
in political discourse fact credibility
and accountability um do these things
matter anymore as far as publishing is
concerned or are they now so relative
has to be irrelevant credibility and
accountability you mean in in in books
themselves
or in political debate generally in
political debate and in the things that
are being published now
well i think
unfortunately we've
we've entered a phase in which the
credibility of the mainstream media the
the traditional forum
in which um
ideas are debated has been called into
question and there's now a significant
part of the public that doesn't trust
uh institutions like the new york times
and the washington post and this is a
serious problem uh because it now means
that we're we have uh i think really
abandoned the the old liberal consensus
not the not the cold war liberal
consensus but the enlightenment
liberal consensus in which the agreement
was that we would work out our
differences through rational debate now
i think we have what i think what i
consider to be cognitive anarchy
uh we have a situation in which
everybody has their own reality and
they're not they're impervious to
arguments from anybody else
well
absolutely the you know credibility of
of the media is something that is a
constant issue that has to be
protected and preserved and i think the
range of things that are published is
the best way to do that so again if you
don't like what you're getting you can
choose something else stockton
california go ahead please you're on the
air
uh morning bill am i appreciate your
program
uh listen rush limbaugh does not speak
for the people of america or the world
i believe that
it's just too much
i don't vote republican or democrat but
i vote in regards to if they back up my
issues
and i believe uh the general public uh
votes that way
and
it's just all about the wealthy and we
have to get back to uh maybe an
independent party or they should speak
to
the politicians and
just vote if it uh concerns your issues
not uh democratic republican thank you
very much doctor yes sir your name
please hi um my name is regen prasad and
i'm an author and a publisher i just
completed a book called why black men
love white women and one of the research
books i used in that work was pat
buchanan's the death of the west i kind
of like the conservative
format and their ideas because listening
to bill o'reilly and sean hannity kind
of makes you smarter in a sense that
uh
you have both sides to choose from now
whether you believe what they're saying
is correct or incorrect doesn't matter
because that's what they feel now if you
sit on the left listening to amy goodman
all day you're going to have this one
side perspective now my personal opinion
i don't want a country run by ru paul
and rush limbaugh you know i want to
balance and i want to see certain things
happening in society where there's an
idea over here and an idea over here and
you can choose either one of those ideas
and you don't have to fight over them
did you publish your own book yeah i
published my own book through my own
company how's it doing it's doing
actually pretty well underground it's
not even out yet it comes out in october
and uh it's it's more of a book on
sexism and and how uh women are used
as fodders for power for men
so i mean you really need both sides as
much as you hate these guys or or or
love these guys
i joined the conservative book club and
one of the things they said which is
pretty weird read less no more
so it's kind of different what they do
because i find liberals to be reading a
lot more than conservative and that is
their mantra read less no more but you
have to know their perspective in order
to argue against it
well
i i think that's a wonderful statement
uh i really applaud you for for
publishing your own book and i and i
agree with your with your point of view
completely uh i think that we we need
both sides of the of the debate uh
otherwise people become uh dogmatic and
they stop thinking uh and that's that's
the the worst thing that could possibly
happen we're running out of time for
this segment i want to ask peter asks
about this store what what role did this
store play in the life of book buyers in
this town well just look around you bro
i mean it's a it really is a magnificent
temple of books of all kinds of all
persuasions
uh and i think that all of us who
are involved with books for a living uh
know that the bookstore is the in a way
the most important place for the for the
book buyer to to find themselves yes you
do have other you know other resources
but boy a great bookstore is a very
special thing and adam bellow when did
you work here well i'm i'm a proud
alumnus of the strand bookstore
but i i began coming to the strand
in my childhood you know my father was a
writer
used to come to new york and uh
i would spend the day with him
and his idea of a good time
was after uh taking me to lunch with his
agent um
and then taking me to see a charlie
chaplin movie
or a may west movie at which he would
laugh at grooriously uh was to take me
to fourth avenue and we'd spend the rest
of the day in in these old bookstores
and i developed it got into my blood i
developed a real taste for these places
and so when i i was on a year off from
college in 1979 i needed a job i came
down here and i fred bass put me to work
uh in what used to be called the
basement uh it's now called the
underground of course we we've dressed
it up a little bit adam bellow's father
is saul bello in case you missed that
point one last call and then we're going
to go to connie we go to kansas city
missouri you're on the air
yes
i'm calling because uh
clinton was recently in lawrence kansas
at the dedication of the bob dole center
and when he was there he spoke about how
we need to listen to each other better
and not be so divided and
not demonize the other side and i heard
that and i've been trying to do that as
a democrat but i have to say after eight
years of clinton being attacked and
investigated for everything and being
accused of being a murderer and some
people really believe that still because
people on the far right put out
videotapes and information like that
it's hard i struggle with that i watch
the newshour i read everything i read
lots of political books but how do i how
can i be open-minded
when i feel like the other side has been
so unfair and even looking at the
republican convention and the democrat
convention
if you compare the keynote speakers you
tell me who was a fairer presentation of
this country zell miller or obama and
that's my question to you peter osnos
last comment
well just on the bill clinton point you
know for eight years he was vilified
demonized he was impeached you published
his book i published the book in 1996. i
didn't publish this one that cost 12
million bucks uh but the truth is after
eight years of being vilified and
attacked and impeached bill clinton left
office
very popular one of the most popular
presidents of modern times he's had a
terrific run and his book has sold
something like two million copies since
it was published his his autobiography
so for all the attacks and all the
vilification i think people in this
country are immensely open-minded when
it or resilient i should say really when
it comes to attacks last comment adam
bellow
well what can i say i i voted for bill
clinton um
uh i my mind wasn't closed uh to what to
what he represented i i had high hopes
for him
i i ended up disappointed in his in his
presidency
um i understand why uh people feel that
the uh political debate has become uh
too harsh and and too partisan i share
that i share that sentiment
my uh my job as an editor
is to find and publish the uh the most
serious uh
uh uh
conservative uh voices i can and to make
sure that they write their books in a
way that is not uh polemical or
rhetorically harsh but that is aimed at
persuading an open-minded opponent
thanks to adam bello who is executive
editor-at-large for doubleday for taking
his labor day weekend and joining us and
also peter osnos publisher and chief
executive of public affairs coming up in
just a moment art spiegelman at the top
of the hour
then an hour later richard brookhiser
and harold evans and then probably the
most uh
difference of opinion we'll hear on this
stage for this afternoon will be between
amy goodman and john fun at three
o'clock east coast time uh here at the
strand bookstore connie who do you have
with you
brian i'm back down on the first floor
of the strand again as we said earlier
there are four floors and you're in that
newly renovated second floor but i'm
down here in the first floor with the
other half of that management team that
we promised to introduce to our viewers
this is nancy bass's father fred bass
hello mr bass hello
do you remember when you moved to this
location oh yes i remember it i can't
tell you the exact date but it was like
46 years ago was it a decision of yours
or your fault no we got kicked out of
our lease
and my dad really wanted to go into a
loft and do a mail-order thing and i
said we'd starve there
so we decided to go in a retail store
and this place became available
we ended up moving from fourth avenue
over here and paying four times the rent
all the fourth avenue booksellers
thought we were insane absolutely insane
and you're the only one left well we're
the only one left but the rent at that
time for us was like a hundred dollars a
month 110 that had just gone up on us
and we moved in here it was 400 a month
rent
wrench
what is the least expensive book that
you sell here in the store well we have
barking books outside for 48 cents each
actually five for two dollars so they're
40 cents each and what's the most
expensive book a shakespeare second
folio for 125 000
there is a quote from you and your
daughter and let me see if i can get
this right it says
when i make it to neat business goes
down absolutely what does that mean and
why is this why is the strand look like
it looks well first of all people like
to see activity uh it's not a sterile
place there's constant flow this cut
this counter here where i do most of my
buying
is always filled with books and they're
priced and they're moved over to the
sorting table
and that's always stacked up and then
they're moved to the different sections
where there are piles on the floor and
every day there's fresh stock coming
and if by chance the buying slows down
here we have
thousands of boxes on our 10th floor
still to be processed so there's never a
slowdown in fresh material coming into
the store and that's the excitement to
restore that there's new books coming in
here new titles new things
and that's the excitement for me because
i'm like a treasure hunt
every day people come in here every day
they want to sell their books to you why
well they have to get rid of them
somehow or another they some of them
need money some of them need space
and some of them are moving and they
just want to recycle what they've got i
don't know if we have or can show our
viewers the video but we took some video
of you doing your your business that
you're buying the other day what's the
key thing in doing that buying well
sellability we look for books that are
sellable uh books that people still want
and that we're not stuck with and we
know what we're stuck with we know what
we have in quantity we know what hasn't
sold
my my buyers here including myself i
hope you know a pretty hip on what's
going on here and we do have a computer
which gives us our inventory and our
sales records and everything else that
we need
so with a combination of a little savvy
and knowledge
and a feel for the books
we do that so it's really what people
want how do you feel about the new
technological changes that are going on
in the book industry i understand that
twenty percent of your sales now are
over the internet over the internet yeah
i think it's great i think it's
stimulating me into the person
people now want a book that go onto the
internet and find it before they used to
have to search from bookstore to
bookstore tedious
hard
and they give up but now it's so easy
they just go on there and find the book
and
find most of the ridiculous prices but a
lot of them have real bargain prices so
but they can shop that's that's the
important thing what can they find at
strand.com
uh our entire stock practically entire
stuff practically our entire stock
there's a there's a small segment that
we
we don't put in it we don't we try and
keep books that are not in great
condition out there and books that are
really too inexpensive to put out there
but otherwise we
we put everything on there
yeah we're told that you are being
pulled a little bit into the next
century by agreeing to that new second
floor and uh well going to the new
coffee shop well that's that's a little
deception there
the second floor i always wanted
the air conditioning no
no air yeah
we've got it now it's in
the air conditioning i really didn't
want because i don't enjoy working in
air-conditioned spaces well we can tell
our viewers it's not air-conditioned on
this floor it will be it will it will be
yeah really the unit's in we just have
to hook it up and get the events in when
we're finished with that floor this this
floor will be air conditioning too and
the coffee shop the coffee shop well i
think i'm being suckered into that
that's uh
i think my daughter has made the
decision and whether i like it or not
it's going to happen one way or another
how many employees did you have here
when your father well uh over on the
fourth street store when your father was
there were one or two one or two one or
two depending on whether he could meet
the payroll for a second person and how
many employees do you have today we have
probably about 110 right now
and
and are going to be hiring more we need
more and two other locations i
understand we we do the park stalls up
on central park opposite the pierre near
the pierre
uh and then we have these the other
store on fulton street and that that
employs about 20 people we're going to
show our viewers your rare book room in
about an hour so but i also want to show
our viewers you have a section of first
editions are they popular with your oh
yeah big big big section we we keep some
representative cases down here just
displaying them things like this
and some lock cases so that people can
see that we do have a rare book room and
people do come and buy out of it
and then we send them upstairs
and i said we just had a man just pick
out a whole batch there's some space
here leather bindings and he just he
went upstairs he had a full basket full
of them
finally how many books do you sell a day
i can't answer that any idea thousands
thousands or easily thousands
and i think i think we we kept track of
what we saw just on the stands outside
and it was running 500 to 1000 books a
day out there on some days and what is
the size of the
of the uh of this business on a yearly
basis how much money do you bring well
we do about 20
give or take a little about 20 million
20 million i hope to bring it up quite a
bit in fact we have to bring it up
expenses keep rising and if i don't uh
if i don't expand the business and and
bring in more sales we'll die
that's the way it is you either grow or
die in this business we're gonna now
take our viewers back upstairs to the
second floor to your daughter
who is standing by to enter to uh
introduce art spiegelman thank you very
much okay pleasure thank you
i'm nancy bass and i'm proud to be one
of the owners of the strand you might
think that i don't look old enough to
own this but i'm standing on the
shoulders of my grandfather and father
who have walked
the floors of the strand since 1927.
we are thrilled to have c-span and its
inspirational founder brian lamb with us
and we believe that now that the
political conventions are over america
can get down to the truly bipartisan
business
of reading and loving great books
i hope that you are enjoying the program
as much as i am and before i introduce
art spiegelmen let me give you a brief
update on what is happening at the
strand
first
our wonderful customers some of whom are
part of families that have been coming
to the strand for generations
have successfully
worn down my dad and he's agreed to a
host of what i call
20th century innovations
we now have books available online
and an elevator linking four floors of
books together
i grew up with customers pleading
for air conditioning
well it's here now
and who knows someday we may even serve
coffee
today art spiegelman honors us by
launching his masterful new creation in
the shadow of no towers
america has waited eight years for this
book
art along with his family lives and
works downtown near ground
zero he gives a powerful account of his
9 11 experiences and the frustrations he
feels about how government
responded to the tragedy
his groundbreaking book mass
won a pulitzer prize this is a favorite
amongst our customers in fact
more copies have been sold here than
from any single bookstore
not surprisingly art has a childhood
fascination with comics beginning with
mad magazine
as a teenager he was drawing for his
weekly paper in rigo park queens
and publishing his own magazine
he had a lazy eye that made it difficult
to see in three dimensions so according
to art cartoons really did seem real to
him
then he went to work out of all places
tops bubble gum company off and on for
20 years we have art to thank for
garbage pail kids
and wacky packs
in 1980 he and his wife founded the
acclaimed and influential magazine of
avant-garde
comics and graphics called raw
he's also a staff writer and illustrator
for the new yorker
little is it known that art's parents
really wanted him to become a dentist
so we are overjoyed that you're here
with us
and that you are not out performing root
canals
here's art spiegelman
thanks for having me uh this is a store
i've come to for generations and uh
uh brian's program is something i put on
whenever npr goes through car talk or a
slow patch i listen to
uh
these uh weekend book shows as my radio
um
i didn't have a chance to really prepare
uh a talk for you and didn't want to
quite read so i'm gonna just free
associate the reason that uh i didn't
prepare anything specifically as i spent
the last few days either on protest
marches or with a press pass from the
new yorker on the floor of the
convention and i'm trying to make a
strip in about two or three days about
it uh so as soon as i leave here i get
to go back to try to do that
um this book was never meant to be it
was never meant to be a book
it grew out of um
a vow made on september 11th after i uh
ran out of the rubble with my daughter
who had just started stuyvesant and my
wife was the art editor of the new
yorker
and turned back on to canal street and
among all these uh memento mori uh
pledges the kind of things you do on new
year's eve
there was a kind of uh rush of affection
for my city which was one uh
very specific response that even
surprised me
uh i can't be sure if i'm a patriot for
america but i know i i pledge allegiance
to the dark blue zone of lower manhattan
and
among the pledges i made was you know
schmuck you really should have made more
comics because i really felt we were
going to die that morning
um
and
the problem with comics is you have to
feel like you're going to live forever
to do them it's a very slow process and
like a farmer paid to not grow wheat
i uh found that i could uh just either
draw or write and do far better for
myself in terms of esteem and ease of
work for a basically lazy person who
overcompensates for his laziness by uh
avoiding comics
and which
somehow in general one is penalized for
being able to somewhat write and
somewhat draw until maybe very recently
where
while the world is doing terribly comics
as graphic novels seem to be doing very
well
it makes me wish that i'd spent the last
30 years fighting for world peace rather
than for comics as literature
um
but
the uh book was
a result of kind of coming out of uh an
extended state of shock that left me
stuck in september 11th and 12th for at
least six months
and
after that i began to just take
my whatever little notes i had gathered
to see what i wanted to do and what i
really wanted to do at first was um
report on what
i subjectively saw felt and understood
of that morning where i was receiving it
unmediated and
have that in opposition to what was
coming to me from uh
my television set which is where the
rest of the planet
was actually better informed about
september 11th than uh i at about 10 in
the morning when i was still
stuck in the uh
bowels of stuyvesant high school at
ground zero um what happened that
morning was francoise and i live on
uh near the corner of canal street came
out of our place to vote early in the
morning saw a plane overhead saw it
crash into a building and then uh fairly
quickly decided we'd better go down and
get our daughter out of the high school
stuyvesant that she just started
attending
a few days before
because it seemed like well gee it could
fall over and land on the school and
then we spent the next um
hour or so trying to find our daughter
among the 3 000 students while we were
in the building the uh
stuyvesant shook and all of its lights
went out when the first tower fell but
we couldn't see that and in the midst of
the panic i went running around the
building um
trying to find nadja who only became
genuinely fearful of what she'd been
seeing right out of her window in the
library of the school uh when she saw me
because then it was obviously real and
not an hallucination
and we got out of the school a few
minutes before the rest of the school
was finally evacuated and uh
when we had gotten to the west side
highway
the second tower fell and unlike what it
looked like on television which was just
this large toxic cloud that appeared
where the tower had been there was a
moment that uh
basically had this 110 story high tower
turning into the glowing bones of itself
just uh
white yellow orange incandescent bones
of a tower
uh above us that seemed to be there
forever before it began to like fall in
on itself and be replaced by that white
cloud and that was some kind of uh
either the largest blue screen effect
i've ever seen on in the world or
uh
a
moment
out of time and i began to try to paint
that and one of the reasons i became a
cartoonist is because i can't paint very
well and i just couldn't get it and
eventually i found that working on a
computer i was able to make something
that's the title page picture of those
towers it looks quite accurate to me and
my wife francoise and my daughter nadja
uh as more like a photograph rather than
a drawing of what that actually looked
like at the moment it fell and that
image informs the ten plates that make
up the core of this book the those
glowing towers that exist somehow out of
time and were what i saw as i point out
in the first page um those crumbling
towers burned their way into every brain
but i live on the outskirts of ground
zero and first saw it all live
unmediated
maybe it's just a question of scale even
on a large tv the towers aren't much
bigger than say dan rather's head
logos on the other hand look enormous on
television it's a medium almost as well
suited as comics for dealing in
abstraction
um so the original plan of drawing what
i saw as opposed to what was on the tv
um became hijacked by what started
coming at me on the tv by
um
a government that seemed to be turning
it into a war recruiting poster
uh
and
i
couldn't even enjoy my trauma in peace
um the what i needed was time to
assimilate that uh intense morning that
lasted for weeks
and it became impossible when the
hijacking itself was seemed to be
hijacked
right around the corner from here
basically is union square and for a long
time no for about five days union square
was the bottom of manhattan
it was where everybody gathered from the
rest of the city where police barriers
wouldn't let you go below unless you had
a a pass i finally felt like i lived in
a gated community i could get down to
canal street
but if i wanted somebody to come visit i
had to go up and bring them down with me
or a babysitter or anything like that
and when i get to union square there was
a moment where i was living not just
near ground zero but in year zero it
wasn't clear from all the people that
were there among the shrines the missing
posters uh
and the like that what this would
inevitably lead to was war uh certainly
not a war in iraq that was beyond most
people's imaginings outside of
um
a cabal but the
original um
feeling of that place was okay
civilization as we knew it has to be
reassessed and we have to figure out
what comes next out of all of the
writings that happened immediately after
september 11th there's an issue of the
new yorker that i did the cover for that
came out about five or six days after
the event which was my black on black uh
ghosts of these towers that come up like
an after image uh of which the cover of
the new book is kind of uh a quotation
of that cover although this black is a
lot lighter than the black those on the
new yorker there's many blacks as ed
reinhardt taught us and the um
this sort of is made to be seen right
away the cover of the new yorker was one
where you couldn't see the silhouette of
the towers right away just sort of come
at you as it sat on your coffee table
sometimes three days later the phantom
limb after image of that tower came up
but in that same issue of the new yorker
there was a piece by susan sontag and it
was a magnet for all of the outrage that
uh um was directed against
a
measured response to what had happened
it was made possible for her by the
luxury of being overseas when the uh
attack happened and yet had it been said
not five or six days after the attack
but two weeks after people could have
heard it instead it was just the
hectoring tone of somebody saying
something in politic at a funeral you
know uh that kept uh her insistence
that uh this was cause for reassessment
to figure out what we've done that kind
of allowed uh an al-qaeda to grow and
flourish uh as opposed to just consider
it a um
a war in some traditional old-fashioned
sense
um
it's her take is one that i ended up
certainly subscribing to and found
myself more and more drawn into uh
having to deal with
uh directly political issues i hate
political cartoons they have a short
life
uh it's kind of like a shelf life like
yogurts you know like uh nothing that
can possibly last a picture of an an
angry picture of a president like after
a few years maybe thank god but after
some few years it's just footnotes and
history books and for a long time i've
been living with the notion that
one could approach comics as one
approaches literature with one uh corner
of an eyeball out for posterity
um
the morning of september 11th when i was
saying gee i should draw more comics
um
i was doing them provisionally it took
me a few months to get started and when
i was doing them i really had no
notion of making any kind of book out of
this i was just figuring while i was
waiting for the world to end and i would
make a page while waiting and then oh
the world didn't end i could make
another and uh they were appearing
primarily in uh what was quaintly called
old europe a coalition of the willing
that included
french magazine desigt german newspaper
was the commissioning paper in an
italian magazine in
holland in belgium
and here it appeared in the forward
where i explained to my editor that uh
these didn't exactly have to do with
being jewish per se the forward being a
final socialist jewish weekly and i was
given the right of returns okay you're
jewish so it was allowed to run there
even though the subject matter wasn't
overtly and specifically about being
jewish except for the fact that it
probably does reduce down to being a
giant ayayoi and they were like monthly
journal pages
uh there were a condensation of what i
had experienced that month and it was
only by the time i'd hit the sixth or
seventh page that i began to slow down
enough uh to say well maybe the world
will last long enough for me to make a
book but a book uh presumes posterity
and i wasn't sure that there could be
such a thing so it's a very provisional
book
uh the pages originally were broadsheet
size like usa today size and maybe
because of that
working in that size that's no longer
the luxury afforded to most cartoonists
and working without an editor because it
all started by me talking to the editor
of the site and complaining about being
edited i see it the normal process of
editing as something very similar to
censorship
and
he said it's okay i'll give you a no
editors clause and as i began doing
these large broad sheets i found myself
uh channeling the old comic strip
characters by the cartoonists who were
making these things as broadsheets in
the first days of the sunday comics
which were born right next to ground
zero on newspaper row and i found myself
drawing myself and my wife francoise not
as me and her quarreling but as maggie
and jiggs i found that a lot of this was
too unreal for me to take uh as a real
given reality and uh started channeling
little nemo in slumberland and
what um i realized about these strips
which were the only things that gave me
solace after september 11th w.h auden
was not doing it for me i couldn't
concentrate on the poem so i just
remembered that line about uh we must
all love one another or die and found i
was getting that same message from
comics where it's easier for me to
understand that language and part of
what made those old comics so poignant
for me
was that they were ephemeral they were
made like a dance they weren't made like
a painting for posterity they were made
to wrap fish 24 hours later they were
part of a news cycle and the working
stips who made them put their entire
personalities in them and their entire
talent which on some
in some cases like windsor mccase was as
great as anybody working in the
so-called high arts but seeing them is
like eavesdropping on a moment long gone
that one has no right to see
and
their very
ephemeralness ephemerality ephemera
their quality of being ephemeral um
uh made them seem to me
uh
somehow now seeing them again as
timeless as say towers that are built to
last forever that also proved to be
ephemeral and uh
um civilizations and experiments and
styles of government that also are
ultimately ephemeral and so there was a
not only timeless moment for me when
these towers fell and those towers
somehow provide the spine from which all
of the other moments that i'm reporting
on jut out on these pages but also a
feeling of disorientation that allowed
the past to be my future like looking
toward these old ephemeral comics gave
me courage to go and make new ones and
as a result this really strange book
object uh is sort of divided into two
towers one being the ten pages the ten
plates i made in their full scale and
one being uh
plates from the early part of the
century uh the comics that ultimately
grew out of being footnotes of me
explaining to people who had never seen
happy hooligan who he was but finding
that
the pages i used looked like they could
have been drawn yesterday and be more
pointed as political cartoons than most
of what's allowed to appear in a very
docile american press so happy hooligan
was this pre
chaplain s hapless bum with a tin can on
his head as a hat and the example i
found was abdullah again the arab clown
has a turban on around his uh tin can
hat and is a an arab clown and dark face
uh in a circus riding a camel he has a
rifle over his shoulder he keeps turning
to wave to his nephews every time he
turns he clobbers the uh camel
inadvertently with his rifle
uh eventually the camel gets rightly
ticked off
lifts him up and kicks him into a tower
of acrobats that tumble
so um since i didn't have any specific
agenda except to sort of vaguely
introduce what this project was maybe i
should like let us take questions
love to
i want to ask you about we i read this
to the audience earlier
uh the ostrich party
you have that in your book
rampaging republican elephants
dim-witted democratic donkeys no wonder
real americans don't bother to vote the
two-party animals are both 19th century
dinosaurs interested only in their own
survival not ours we need a third party
that actually represents us a new and
revolutionary ostrich party is that your
philosophy no it was back when i did
that page this is the nature of ephemera
certain pages come back into being
present other ones are comments on the
moment and may indeed have reason i
still basically believe that our way of
voting is nuts ranging from the
electoral college to the big money
that's involved in mounting these
elections to the fact that we don't have
room for multiple rounds of elections
make this a very distorted system and
yet right now i'd be glad to donate that
particular panel to nader uh and let him
use it for his recruit recruiting
in the current structure to vote for the
ostrich party is uh really to condemn
yourself to not having a vote we are
left with a not only a polarized
electorate but a polarized set of
choices that are very urgent so you're
going to vote in november um absolutely
uh as always with a nose clip on um and
basically i think this is probably the
most urgent election i've ever lived
through and i not only didn't want to
draw political cartoons when i was doing
these pages but found myself dragooned
into it but um i'm not interested in
politics i've grown up like most
americans thinking of politics as
optional the way you might be interested
in the knicks or something you could be
interested in democrats and republicans
and i was not that interested in either
but more and more i'm stuck with that
stupid t-shirt of all all politics is
personal um
at this point one has no exit strategy
short of appealing to these uh two
parties to find a way out of the most
dangerous heart of the situation we're
in toward at least a somewhat less
dangerous situation and and basically as
a result the way i've positioned myself
and think about it now having come out
of uh for three three days because i
couldn't stand it one day on the
republican floor at madison square
garden is i found what i was meeting
there reptilian cold-blooded and
reptilian and as a result i don't hold
out that much personal hope uh that
kerry will meet my needs but just out of
class interest meaning biological class
interest i would like to see
a mammal in the white house
and
[Applause]
in better times
in better times i would like to find a
member of my own species
one one of the reasons we do these
programs is to let people from around
the country
react to what they're hearing here in
new york city i'm sure they'll have your
reaction i want to make sure that people
here in the audience that have something
they want to say or comment feel free to
walk to the microphone plus we have the
numbers on the screen for art spiegelman
those who support president bush you can
see the number those who support uh
senator kerry and those that consider
themselves in a third party or not going
to vote at all would let me go back to
you though if there's nobody at the
microphone uh we'll take a call
are you part of the problem though if
you say you've never been interested in
politics half america doesn't vote
i was part of the problem i did vote and
it's not like i was totally
disinterested i actually know more about
politics than i do about the knicks but
i am not uh
um
as
for i haven't i hadn't been as focused
on this before september 11th i found
myself uh doing images for the new
yorker that definitely had uh political
content certainly during the amidu
diallo uh
mess in new york i did a picture that
got my mayor very angry um and i did
stuff about uh the clinton and monica uh
event but i didn't find that that was
the general focus for me that like i
remained narcissistically uninvolved and
if anything i guess i would like to make
sure i can't believe that anybody
watching c-span is part of the problem
of the 100 million people that aren't
registered though so i won't go into
that we are
we are here at the strand on this sunday
afternoon live all afternoon long taking
your calls talking to different people
richard brookheiser harold evans will
join us at the top of the hour and a
gentleman back here has a comment please
give your name hi my name's scott
rosenbaum uh
comics and sequential art are a way of
telling a story and it definitely has
something to do with the passage of time
and you did that masterfully in mouse
i'm curious as to
know whether your style of storytelling
has changed when you're trying to
portray a moment as you described as
being out of time
um existing out of time thank you and
tell us first what mouse is for those
who have not read it uh mouse is uh
what's now called a graphic novel when i
did it was just a comic book that needed
a bookmark um
and what i wanted to do is um tell the
story of my parents who had survived
auschwitz through the deposition i took
over a period of years with my father
who had been uh
in auschwitz and tell the story of my
life with my father in the then present
and uh in the course of making that i
found that the characters all needed to
have masks on so i had mouse masks for
the jews cat masks for the uh
nazis and
dog masks for the gis and so on
this is a very different work i know
that it's being billed as
his first graphic novel since mao's i
don't even know that this is a graphic
novel it's a very fat comic book it's
got very few pages in it it's on
cardboard pages uh next one i think i'm
gonna do on stone because then i only
have to do two pages and i can
kind of carry them around like that but
um essentially the reason for the
cardboard pages is i needed i did these
as very large sheets nobody would
publish a book this size and by doing
them as a children's board book there's
no gutter and i can have these strange
layouts uh fill up the scale that they
needed to have to deal with these 110
story towers to answer the question
about time standing still essentially
what i found myself doing was constantly
referring back to this
image by the repetition of the image
forcing you into that timeless moment
and then allowing shards of other
thoughts to come into it to be flashes
of uh momentary anecdote and time but
ultimately this thing is like a the
tower is like a
um
the memento mori that keeps coming back
and what i needed to make on these pages
specifically returned me back to the
kind of comics i was making before mouse
that were much more structural it's a
good word to use in context of talking
about these two towers but ultimately
um
in mouse it was my job to get out of the
damn story's way uh and that meant
anything formal that was interesting to
me had to be sublimated it's there but
it's not to be seen unless somebody's
actually staring at it as a comic
scholar it's just meant to be absorbed
eventually you forget you're reading a
comic i suspect and you forget that
there are cat and mouse heads on these
people here for example by having a page
structured
so that
when you first approach it you see these
two towers on this large image and if
you start reading from left to right and
get over to that top of that tower over
there you don't know whether to read
down or go to that tower or go here and
essentially the dislocation that you
feel with the pages you're trying to
find your orientation is uh the
dislocation that i felt on september
11th let's say in the middle there you
have a
picture of dan rather art that you've
drawn it says maybe it's just a question
of scale even on a large tv the towers
aren't much bigger than say dan rather's
head
any reason for that well yeah
essentially
most of the information that we all get
the way we're all plugged in is through
the same cameras and i can't be sure
that there's a war in iraq because it
could be some kind of philip k dick
movie that's being projected outward to
me i am sure the towers fell
uh you can't be because i could be part
of the philip k dick movie on television
for you watching but um but essentially
it was a matter of trying to sort out
what i experienced and what uh was
coming at me otherwise let me grab a
call from san mateo california for art
spiegelman go ahead please you're on the
air
yes art um
your your depiction here seems to be
pretty much one-sided um and and very
very um
very anti-bush okay
um
that's true which is true which is true
um
is there any way of getting any kind of
objective
um sense
to
to uh your point of view
i mean yes what if there was more of a
left-wing press prominent in america one
could triangulate
uh in other words right now the
so-called objective point of view seems
to be represented by anything that's to
the left of fox which still leaves us
very very far away from something to
triangulate from
and i don't think it's my job to do that
one more time one thing that was
interesting to me on the floor is in
order to not be ashamed when i was at
the republican convention on the third
day i wore my protest t-shirt that i'd
worn on sunday which was a handmade
shirt that said pray for a secular
future
um
and
at that point um i was sitting in the
bleachers somewhere and a guard pulled
me out to read it he read it i suspect
he didn't understand the word secular so
he left me back in and then i tried to
go down and exchange my bleachers pass
for a floor pass to get closer to where
the action was and at that desk i was
turned away by a secret service person
who did know the word secular and said
takes a minute to get that one and they
said you're supposed to be a journalist
meaning i couldn't go down on the floor
with that message on and meanwhile other
journalists were going on the floor with
bush cheney pins
what does that tell you about
objectivity monroe louisiana you're next
please go ahead for art spiegelman
first let me say
thank you for smoking i thought that had
been outlawed in your town it was and
bloomberg's police are now free to have
a large scooter procession to meet me at
the door
and second from your lips to god's ear
that we give a pink flip to the reptile
who is in the white house
okay i'm with you let's go to the
audience here do you have a question
please and give us your name
hi my name is kate and i'm wondering if
you saw the most recent michael moore
film
and what your views were on that and
also
right yes
and also
any words on chomsky if you
want to bring that into the discussion
okay um great you know one thing when i
was talking about this triangulation uh
between fox and something else
interestingly enough the triangulation
does exist with a book by chomsky that
can get to be a bestseller with a lot of
uh journalism being put into book form
now uh that in some ways for a long time
the fourth estate sort of fell asleep
and became to my eyes uh fifth column it
wasn't there for us and as a result the
real information that one needed that
should have been part of the daily press
and part of the magazine press tended
very often to end up in hard covers and
uh that means that those who can read
and are willing to read can actually get
a larger picture of the landscape we're
living in unfortunately that's not uh
the bulk of the electorate that does get
its news through quick flashes as a
result michael moore's film seems to
have been useful to find people who
weren't getting that same information by
trolling the internet for uh more
sophisticated news sources for me there
was relatively little surprising in uh
michael moore's films except the footage
of uh people pelting uh when he was
trying to get to the white house right
after his election that wasn't stuff i
saw on television and the uh black
caucus's tragic uh attempt to get a
recount of votes in 2000 also wasn't
widely seen except in that movie i'm
grateful for michael moore he's much
more focused a human than i am um my
work does have a political dimension but
in this particular case it's not as
focused i try to do a lot of things at
once uh in each of these monthly journal
reports that made up the no towers
plates but uh what michael moore does is
he has a kind of class analysis or at
least a class hatred that keeps him very
focused and it means that everything's
coming from somewhere i was very
impatient with that woman that became
the star of the second half of his film
because she's uh wrapped up in some kind
of provincial flag waving uh taking
solace in uh
a in a lot of slogans and uh religions
and then finally wakes up when her son
is affected and by his sympathy for her
he was able to pull out a narrative that
was well worth having and so i'm
grateful for it i found myself in a way
reduced to being sort of a local michael
moore uh when the strip was appearing in
europe in that michael moore's uh
reception as you know in in uh cheesy
surrender monkey country was uh really
awesome and uh it was a ratification
that not all americans are uh gop
uh republicans and i think that although
it wasn't my intention my strip gave uh
some solace to europeans who are very
confused by america's foreign policy
right now little rock arkansas go ahead
please you're on with art spiegelman
good afternoon gentlemen
um i wanted uh to make two points if i
could
one is address to
nancy bass if she's around i noticed
that on their table
of bestsellers there were two notable
omissions
that is of course unfit for command and
a soldier's life by general frank
and to mr spiegelman and to the audience
that's there
the contempt
that you feel towards
what you call the religious right
and the fact that we out here are stupid
and don't breathe stupid but i do have
contempt
your arrogance your your arrogance is
really beyond belief as was mr bello who
said he's glad he was in the middle of a
bunch of evangelicals well he doesn't
know any evangelicals if he knew some i
mean who is this religious right anyway
it's people i've grown up with all my
life
and uh well i saw an interesting piece
in the times about how the event
evangelicals aren't even as monolithic
as they've been presented uh in the
press either today or yesterday's
op-ed
uh column of the times and that's
probably true i know that i don't know
if those two books are here but i know
there was only when i was stuck in an
airport in mississippi that i saw the
left behind books i've never seen them
in my book stores in new york um this is
the timothy lahay books
let me ask are you still there caller
allegheny
except in an airplane and i would bet
you that that's true of most of the live
people i suppose i guess they're alive
they're certainly not thinking
who are sitting in the audience uh thank
you very much for listening as a person
who is a uniter not a divider we can be
sure that bush didn't succeed at least
in that mission right
let me ask you a question that keeps
coming up uh based on what you're saying
and what we saw when we covered last
sunday's demonstration out
there was a big huge fox sign out in
front of the building and as people came
by they said some very strong
four-letter word things about fox news
and i know the audience is very much
unhappy with fox news why is it a town
that is so liberal
with all the publishing industries and
all the media and everything it gets so
upset about one company that has
somewhere between two and three million
viewers every night
out of 294 million why is it you get
well it sounds like all of the biggest
ratings for the convention coverage
certainly were fox news recently but six
million people watched them yeah 294
million why is it you get so
basically the marching orders that come
from there get repeated the stories that
get distorted on fox news get
disseminated further than just being uh
left to being a provincial
news station by the rest of a media that
i'm also unhappy with you know like it's
been reported incorrectly that i left uh
the new yorker in protest i've seen that
uh a number of times it was a distortion
of something i'd said in an italian
magazine that got repeated here to have
left the new yorker would be just like
beating your wife because you're angry
at george bush you know like uh
essentially this wasn't the enemy ever
on the other hand even the new yorker uh
at a certain moment took on the
conventional wisdom and did something
unheard of which is in his talk section
the editor chose to endorse uh the war
as a reluctant talk um and it took a
long time for things like to see more
hirsch pieces to appear that gave me
confidence in my magazine again and i
found that in general i was just in a
kind of internal exile where when i
would look at
news sources coming from france coming
from england i was getting a much bigger
picture than what i was getting from any
place in america and what i believe fox
has done is not so much uh become the
central and only loudspeaker but it
seems to be the place from which a lot
of news emanates so that the rest of the
news takes what's set on fox as if it
were a fact resida california for art
spiegelman he'll be with us for another
10 15 minutes go ahead please okay uh
first of all
i've been actually waiting a couple of
decades to let mr spiegelman know you
know what uh
thank you very much for the garbage pail
kids cars i'll tell you right now that
that was the best idea and i think
that's actually what gives you the
credibility as a writer you know or as a
cartoonist you know from one animator to
another anyways uh getting straight to
my point it's not really a question i
was just a couple of uh
statements here basically um
i believe that uh the way you depict
certain points
for america is
basically the proper way to be done
i think people will listen more
and um
also i think you know
as uh america's been uniting after a
9 11 and all that i think
i think you know we should all just kind
of
open our minds a bit more and just kind
of like you know
let it all go like you know especially
the people who were demonstrating
outside the republican convention i i
think that's that's that's a bit
immature you know even for people with
that kind of belief because it's like
we're not getting anything done right
and uh one more thing is if sir if you
haven't received the pulitzer prize yet
i think i think you're you're on the
road for that thanks carla when did you
receive your pulitzer in 1992 it was a
special pulitzer's like the special
olympics it was a separate
category um
to respond to what this last caller said
i just say that uh yes it's true that
words and pictures can plug in in a way
that uh print alone can't and pictures
that stand still the way they do in
comics might be more useful in terms of
allowing reflection than the steady
parade of stuff that happens on tv the
only thing i can't really agree with is
that the protesters were immature
there's no other way to have a dialogue
than to insist on having the side that
tends to be muzzled and muffled to come
out and indicate its displeasure it
should be seen as part of an ongoing
process what scared me was that for a
full year the year that this book uh
documents is really from 2002 to 2003 it
ran from september 11th to september
11th during that year there wasn't any
dissent the papers were filled with uh
things that indicated a kind of fearful
response to being accused of being
unpatriotic as soon as the presidential
election season and somehow began
revving up which was uh september 2003
all of a sudden a vigorous debate became
part of what was possible and necessary
just if nothing else uh to show that we
had a democracy and what i'm afraid of
is that that can go back to sleep again
i was beginning to feel like i could
avoid politics because finally the
newspapers were awake we were beginning
to track down where abu ghraib uh was
sourced what brought that about and then
all of a sudden the press went into a
binge of ronald reagan celebrating that
was like a northeast right to unplug
every electronic device in my house
for a full week the abu ghraib story
disappeared and only now is it even
beginning to inch back into public
consciousness coming up in about 20
minutes we'll have richard burkhauser
and harold evans then an hour later john
fund and amy goodman and our stop here
at the strand bookstore we go to uh lady
in the audience your name please hello
my name is arlene and i wanted to tell
people when i speak i speak as an
american
and i have been working for three years
as a clinical social worker with many
many 911 family members
even in this room my husband and i have
called up repeatedly
we did our homework we went into every
single newspaper and found articles and
we even told on c-span where conspiracy
nuts
i brought with me
june 1st 2001 to me is one of the most
important days in american history
that the joint chiefs of staff
changed the directive from
1997 that said
only in a hijacking commanders are
stripped of the responsibility to act
that norad was forbidden to proceed when
they got the phone call at 8 13 that
there were four planes being hijacked
that same day in norad's magazine they
showed a picture a bin laden in the
middle with four planes so when they
said they could not imagine any planes
being hijacked and people were screaming
in new york city that day before the
towers went down what happened to our
air force we find out
that they had norad had a command center
right outside atlantic city they were
waiting for hours to proceed and they
were told not to so when we're concerned
about asking the questions like you say
in an open debate as soon as we start
asking these questions the family
members we're told shut up the american
government will go crumbling down
thank you
i found myself on september 12th 13th
and 14th while sort of somehow
channeling that new yorker cover and uh
channeling my tv set and the web that i
was getting more and more into things
that would leave me in grassy knoll land
for the next few years and i ended up
having to
protect myself from it by deciding it
wasn't necessary for me to figure out uh
whether or not
uh there was a conspiracy that led to
uh the
towers
attack
it was enough to see how that attack was
instrumentalized and stay therefore on
grounds where that just wasn't the most
urgent aspect of what was happening for
me and that
whoever did this with whatever knowledge
and
possible
ways of averting it that had been
ignored some of which came out in the
911 commission some of which as you
point out haven't been allowed to come
out what was more important in the short
term and
like i said for months and months i felt
i was living in the short term
uh
i believe it's more important to see how
that thing was being used we were a
united nation when
if you'll forgive the phrase out in
parts of the country that don't like
that we were a united country
uh for a while and
i was even amazed at how new york was
embraced as part of america uh after
after 9 11 and yet um
that that moment was squandered we found
ourselves not only divided in america
but with a world that's divided against
us as well this book uh your book in the
shot of no tires uh the price here at uh
strand is 14.95 the list price is 19.95
isn't that amazing it is amazing i'm i'm
impressed now now is this out now
available for people uh official pub
date is uh september 7th but my friends
tell me they've been seeing it in stores
all over all right december 7th
september september i'm sorry september
7th so in the next couple days in fact
one of the questions i was asked in an
interview recently from someone in iowa
for uh for a newspaper was well you say
that bush is exploiting september 11th
do you think you are by coming out with
this book and my immediate snarled
response was i was here and he wasn't
here until the 14th of september when
all he did was snarl up traffic further
um essentially this was based on
visceral responses that didn't really
even have exactly a political agenda it
didn't start out being that this picture
that caused a lot of trouble for me
which was uh in the second of my pages
that had bin laden on one side and bush
on the other as i try to escape into my
old sunday comic supplements that says
equally terrorized by al qaeda and his
own government our hero looks over some
ancient comics pages um
that
image was not even meant
as a political cartoon it was just
trying to describe my visceral response
to what was being yanked away from me
which was uh trying to understand what
happened when these cultures collided
into a tower let's go to new york city
next call you're on there please go
ahead
uh good afternoon brian and mr
spiegelman i just have a comment and a
question first i'd just like to let you
know in response to your comment before
that you'd wish that you were spending
more time advocating world peace as
opposed to
having comics accepted as literature i
just like to let you know that 12 years
ago when i was 16 i read your book mouse
and because of it it opened my heart
i've been a social worker and i became
that in large part because of the book
and my question for you is do you feel
that there was a connection between the
way people were treating each other as
you eloquently expressed a mouse
and in the events of 9 11.
thank you very much well thank you and
thanks for that first statement
especially i must say that when i made
mouse my only goal was to make a comic
book that needed a bookmark and i didn't
think it would have any useful function
in the world uh
nevertheless i'm glad that it does i'm
grateful um the only crossover between
uh mao's and this work is that for the
first time in my life i was in a
situation where i wasn't in the middle
of problems of my own making of which
i've made many uh instead i was at one
of those crossroads where world history
and personal history
meet i was on that particular corner of
ground zero and as a result my father's
admonition to always keep your bags
packed took on added meaning
um i don't in any way compare uh what i
went through there as a witness to an
event of uh
[Music]
whatever magnitude it was to what it
meant to survive the death camps uh
and
on the other hand
i feel that because of my own
predilections i find that dealing with
where my own personal life crosses over
with things that affect somebody besides
me is probably the most fertile terrain
for me to be functioning in it which is
why somewhere in the introductory essay
i talk about returning to comic strips
because disaster is my muse and it seems
like there's a lot to draw about these
things one more call and then to the
audience and then we'll wrap it up with
art spiegelman here at the strand
bookstore we go to memphis tennessee
hello hello art and brian i've really
enjoyed this and i will buy your book
it's reasonably priced so i'll buy more
than one i
really liked what you said about let's
pray for a secular nation and
liberal has become such a dirty word and
we're always supposed to be portrayed as
foaming at the mouth and i watched dale
miller the other night i could barely
stand it he was fairly well frothing at
the mouth
and i think the propaganda
from the bush side is what i object more
to anything else
and the fact that you put your finger on
it people don't read as much print as
they used to so your book's going to
serve a real useful purpose and to give
you something that's an applaud i teach
holocaust studies
my teenagers in my classes brought me
mouse and wanted to use it in class and
so we did and i want to thank you for
that very much thank you
um
probably the most important thing i
could respond to several but i know
where our time is running out is this
thing about uh
uh a secular nation um
my t-shirt which said pray for a secular
future uh seems to me like it touches on
the most central issues right now which
is about still doing these pages and
maybe it'll grow into being another book
it seems to me is the the war between
heaven and heck
you know uh that uh
even
the uh
evangelical christians who were
brought up by a caller uh may well be
served by a government that remains
strictly secular one of the most
interesting things that happened in
france in the last week was the giant
outpouring of arab support within france
for releasing the french journalists who
are held hostage this is because france
has insisted on keeping its government
completely secular in its society
completely secular it allows religion to
flourish and doesn't impose that
religion anywhere and right now what i
find the most dangerous are the uh
fundamentalist ideologues whether
they're living on the west bank
somewhere in the uh
in afghanistan or somewhere in red zone
states uh that to me is the culture
clash that has to be dealt with most
effectively in the future for us to have
a future yes sir your name
hi my name is todd owen and i've got two
rather unrelated questions first
uh with the anniversary of 911 just five
days away how do you feel our
perspective on 9 11 is changing as each
year passes and secondly i read
somewhere that you smoke two packs a day
one and a half it's the press is full of
distortions how do you how do you feel
about the smoking is part of your public
image and what are your thoughts on
quitting
my thoughts are okay i'll take the
smoking one first because maybe it's
easier um
let's see i don't endorse smoking i'm in
fact i'm having a
uh
um
deadly battle with my daughter trying to
convince her to not be a smoker even
though that may sound insane from a
family in which there's a chain smoker
but i got addicted to this i tried to
stop for a year and a half mouse which
took 13 years could have taken 11 and a
half all i did for a year and a half was
not smoke it was my day job and
eventually when i went back to it i was
introduced to a uh
russian
a person was introduced to me as a
famous russian writer and i was
twitching because i wasn't spoken i said
i'm sorry i'm trying to not smoke at
this party and he says i used to smoke i
stopped completely i said how did you
continue writing he said i don't write i
am now doctor
and i just felt that there was no way
for me to continue in the patterns i was
in unless i was smoking even if it means
shortening my life for that and
um i certainly don't recommend it to
anybody else i just feel trapped because
i'm not allowed indoors unless i'm
breaking the law uh smoking about the
the other issues september 11th i'll
just read you the last three panels that
follow the uh cowboy boots falling on my
city of my templates which says the
towers have come to loom larger than
life but they seem to get smaller every
day happy anniversary
art speaking we're out of time thank you
very much
again the book is in the shadows of no
towers art spiegelman available here for
14.95 and in your bookstores other
places for 19.95
we have connie dudley somewhere in the
strand area with people let us know who
you have connie well brian we have been
spending the uh
most of our time so far in the first
three floors or rather the underground
the first and the second floor of the
strand now we're going to take you to
the third floor which is the rare books
area which is one of the things that the
strand specializes in and we're pleased
to have with us for this segment two
people who have spent a lot of their
lives talking about special books rare
books and aquarian books
first of all marvin maudlin
you have a history with this store yes i
do when did you first start working at
this 1951 i began working at the strand
and what did you do
i was uh i was a as ben bass the owner
said i was his man friday i did a little
of everything i learned the whole book
trade in that first year
i was excited about it then i went into
the coast guard when i came out i was in
business for myself and then
i went back to the strand because they
off they thought i was very good and
they wanted me back again and so i
stayed with them for the rest of the i'd
say out of the 52 years about 48 of them
have been with the strand and you had in
your later years have been specializing
in this rare book area well i am uh the
generalist buyer i do buy for the rare
book department certainly i buy for all
the departments actually
uh but so many books come in over the
counter of a more ordinary kind that in
the last few years they've been most
interested in having me
be the person to look go after the
rarities well let's take a look um at
this floor which is the whole floor is
dedicated to the rare book section what
would people find here
well they'll find something in almost
every department whether it's art books
as you can see really unusual art books
not the common thing
they will find sets they will find
inscribed and signed editions they will
find uh
uh material on economics on politics on
you name it on medicine on everything
because uh the the strand bookstore
i is a huge generalist and the uh the
rare book department is a little mirror
image of the strand as i once said
nicholas baz baines is also with us a an
author about the book industry but also
a collector and a specialist in this
area what makes this room important well
the fact first of all that it's here why
because so many
open shops as we call them in the
business second-hand bookstores uh
antiquarian book stores are closing down
throughout the united states and the
fact that the strand exists and not only
exists but exists triumphantly in new
york city makes it so important and so
essential i can think for myself
having been coming here for the last 25
or so years finding books here in this
very room in fact just 10 or 15 minutes
before we went on the air i was browsing
through the books about books section
over there found a few books that i
don't know about no no nothing about but
to come in here and to find books that i
never knew existed and which i then
purchase and find essential to my work i
think the unpredictability of the fact
that you you're going to encounter books
that you don't even know are going to be
here and yet when you see them you know
how essential they are to having just
the fact that it exists and that not
only that it exists but that it thrives
right here in manhattan what makes a
rare book
uh what makes a book well you know
there's any number of different uh the
fact that two people want uh what only
one of them can have i would say you
know the desirability uh if if a book is
scarce and more than one person wants it
and somebody is is willing to uh to pay
more for it than it cost when it was
brand new i mean there are any number of
different definitions that you could
apply for what makes a real book marvin
maudlin show us a rare book from this
area let me show you why it's rare well
first let me just mention i am the
co-author of book row
which is a um
it's a
history anecdotal and pictorial history
of the antiquarian book trade
and uh i'm the co-author roy meador is
the other person he's out in ann arbor
and
i've been busy with that among other
things for the past many years
but what makes a book rare
is
the
desirability in relation to the scarcity
of the object
a rare book
a book may be very rare and not valuable
because nobody wants it so rarity in
itself is not the key thing the key
thing is desirability as well as where
as uh the let's say the fewness of
copies remain give us an example well
right here for example
is the
second folio shakespeare
now the second folio shakespeare is
actually
the first edition of shakespeare
uh of the collected i should say the
collected shakespeare uh
which was published in 1632 the first
was 1623
but they're really from the same place
the same same sheets are being used
again only in those years in that
century 17th century it would be a long
time before
the first issue and the second issue
today it might be a matter of days or
weeks book row for instance is in the
second uh
uh printing now and that it just got uh
printed in
in january uh 5 000 copies and then
another 2500 copies uh came out in june
so uh and that's a short space of time
that's but this is the 20th century 21st
i should say not the 17th what would
that sell for well this particular copy
is a
quite a wonderful copy it has various
problems but none of them that would uh
put it this way
a strand wants 125 000 for it which is a
fair as far as i can see
all the research that's gone into it is
a very fair price
so that's that's rare
indeed
uh one of the great ones one of the
great rarities everybody knows
shakespeare and everyone would imagine
that
an early
collected edition would be valuable
let me mention the second thing
this is rare
in itself it's not at all rare
but what's rare about this is
there's a bullet hole someone shot this
was mentioned in the wall street journal
this is a book
that somebody shot a bit of bullet hole
into and
it nearly went through but it lodged the
bullet is still in there
now
is that rare
well it's a the sort of thing that can
happen amongst when you buy collections
of old books you don't know everything
that's in it but suddenly we see this we
turn it up i don't know it may have been
fred bass it may have been one of the
other employees here who discovered it
but whatever it is it as as as a
particular copy that is rare
nick that's basically a book that
otherwise may i point out it has no
value whatsoever i mean
i mean it's not so this is an instance
where the book i don't mean any
disrespect to the book but i don't know
that that it is a particularly scarce or
valuable or collectible book and it's
all right but it's the story behind the
artifact and as we say as i like to
think every every book collector is a
storyteller that there's a narrative
attached to every book every collection
and this is a story that's attached to
this book what really makes it
interesting is we don't know what
happened who shot the book did it save a
life was it was it a stray shot who
knows but it is interesting so it
becomes a collectible a curiosity a
curiosity i would call it a curiosity
more than i call it a real book in
keeping with the political uh our
political uh discussion today i want to
go to this new magazine that you are
calling this for mr baines find books
and collections and i'm going to open it
up and there is an article in here
written about
presidential memoirs isn't that
interesting so appropriate so
appropriate for our discussion today and
it goes through some of the presidential
memoirs obviously the one that everybody
still talks about since ever since the
clinton book came out is the uh the
ulysses s grant memoir i think that the
grant memoir and there might be some
disagreement with that i know marvin and
i talked a little bit about it before
the program but i think that you will
find among historians and among
collectors the grants memoirs two
volumes published 1865 and 1866 i think
six years
is the is the standard by which all
other presidential memoirs are measured
it's well written he read it he wrote it
by himself the long hand he was dying of
cancer he was destitute he was working
with mark twain he really needed money
to support his family and then he died
and it was published posthumously what
is really very funny and very cute
you'll have people call every once in a
while and say i've got a signed grant's
memoirs because all of these editions
were
printed with facsimile signatures tipped
in not not obviously a genuine but
people will see it and they'll think
that they have assigned grant's memoir
which is impossible because he died
before it was pretty but
in terms of the text in terms of the
writing also historians will tell you
that that is the finest presidential
memo of 13 apparently that have been
written of the 42 ex-presidents 13 have
written their memoirs let me show you
the books of nicholas baz baines if
you're interested in taking a look at
what he's been writing about a splendor
of letters the permanence of books in an
impermanent world among the gently mad
strategies and perspectives for the book
hunter in the 21st century patience and
fortitude
a roving chronicle of book people book
places in book culture and the book that
you appeared on book notes for a gentle
madness bibliophiles biblio is a
bibliomaterial
bibliomes and the eternal
passion for books now uh and also marvin
maudlin this was your book this is your
book that you have out now book row
which is all about this area that we've
been talking about yes it is and
finishing up today would you read a
little bit the poem i would your book
yes i would
uh it's him to fourth avenue by eli
siegel the man who
taught me most about books and the world
itself i knew him and i loved him as i
think america will know him and loved
him but let me give you now let me give
you a sampling of his hymn to fourth
avenue which is a kind of summarization
of
what books are all about and what you
can find in all bookstores
are
all the books awaiting for you in the
crowded bookshops of fourth avenue
experiences galore
experiences you'll adore
bibliographical thrills
new as the hills
mental fountains emotional mountains
second section in books you'll find what
you are looking for
in books is that which makes existence
more
our hopes in life
are often in an old bookstore
three a book in schulte's perhaps can
explain a puzzling thing
a book to lesson pain is now in wisers
rich in mental gain
four
surprise is waiting
on the bible shelves
green bookstore volumes tell about
ourselves and bring us news the world
the word that shines and delves five the
same is true of all the other shops our
lives are there and all their skips and
hops in all their valleys all their
mountaintops
come then and see what's in fourth
avenue ah all the wealth that's old and
all that's new and what a page
a book can do and do marvin maudlin is
co-author of book row nicholas vazbane
has a series of books and your new one
coming out next year
uh every book its reader will be my take
on reading and
should be a lot of fun this is the third
floor of the strand's rare book of the
strand which is the rare book section
and now we're going to take you back
down to the second floor which is uh
which has brian lam and some new guests
brookheiser you brought with you the
first book you ever bought at strand
what year was it
1976 summer of 1976.
what is it let me hold it up there you
go
it's ovid's metamorphosis translated by
william golding
which was um uh done in the late 1500s
it's the version of avid that
shakespeare would have read
uh ezra pound called it the most
beautiful book in the english language
ezra pound was an enthusiast
but there's some nice stuff in it why
were you interested in this book at the
time you bought it
i saw
i saw it on the shelf
i'd read some of it in college not not
in latin i don't don't have any latin
but
i knew this was an important
book and shakespeare had been influenced
by it so i thought oh great here it is
let me pick it up and i paid
i paid four dollars for it
harold evans when you were running
random house a lot of those books you
sent out to people to review ended up
here
for half price having been raider trust
me
what did you think of that practice i
never bind it i mean you know reviewers
of books are an impoverished lot most of
them are writers who don't have any
money
and so if they can get ten dollars even
for a book by richard brookheiser which
is worth much more i couldn't object as
a publisher the more people who read the
better for a publisher and for
civilization if you'd like
in all the books that you published how
many years were you randomized i said
what was the most interesting experience
not necessarily the best book or the
worst book but what was the most
interesting publishing experience and
why the most interesting thing was when
i arrived when i had been a student here
in the 50s before everybody was born in
the audience
and i bought my first book in san
francisco for a dollar which was uh the
american past by roger butterfield
uh i was enthused by
the modern library
which i stocked my
poor student library with modern library
so when i got to random house in 1990 i
said let's restart the modern library of
classics
and the
some of the most experienced people said
forget it
classics have had it you'll never revive
the modern library
and so i found some enthusiasm in the
sales staff who were in the bookstores
they were in the trenches as it were
so then we designed the uh a new a new
design we changed the typeface and we
put out the modern library and it's been
a phenomenal success and that
to me was the most exciting single thing
of all the best sellers i had
to restart the model library and put
classics again and just find new
classics and put them out there which
classic sells the best
jane austen i remember putting we were
having a conference and we had pride and
prejudice i said let's do all the jane
austen novels we sold 100 000 copies
just bang like that of the books that
sell the best uh nietzsche sells
surprisingly well
uh george eliot's uh middle march uh
missed the
myth sell the greek myth sell
fantastically well
going back to
a few aristotle sales but not a huge
amount richard bruckheiser you've done
books on george washington john
adams alexander hamilton and now
governor morris which one of those was
the most interesting experience
well washington is the greatest man
of of all my subjects and of the whole
founding he just absolutely is
but the person if you wanted uh to take
one of the founding fathers to dinner
or if
you just lost the closest person in your
life and you wanted some consolation
or if you were in a jail someplace and
you needed one phone call
the one you would
turn to in all those occasions would be
governor morris
he would be the one who would take the
call who would show up who would make
some effort also if you wanted if you if
you all of a sudden wanted next person
at a dinner party you know he would be
the best person to plug in at the table
just a wonderful wonderful man how come
so many people refer to him as governor
morris and you say governor moores well
the name is spelled
it was his mother's maiden name it's a
french name g-o-u-v-e-r-n-e-u-r
but um
uh you know over the years uh the
pronunciation got changed and so you
know people called him governor they
called him governor nobody called him
governor
the most startling thing up here in the
front of the room today are richard's
socks and i want to make sure the
audience gets a chance to see the color
of his socks is there any uh message
there at
all these are my uh ulster county socks
ulster county socks here at strand
bookstore i thought you might be they
match your type brian they do
they're political colors aren't they
really
i've got a lot of blue in my shirt as
well we have a mock cover here of a new
book coming out by harold evans they
made america what is this all about
this is about
over two centuries from governor morris
and alexander hamilton
how america which was supposed to be a
rural society thomas jefferson's ideas
how it became the largest industrial
power in the world how did it move from
a tiny rural society of three million
people to become this vast industrial
part in inventing and innovating
television every time you make a cell
phone call electricity and so i thought
and curiously enough nobody has ever
surveyed 200 years of american
innovation and dan burstein did a little
bit
so i went and i spent a year researching
the greatest innovations and the
greatest innovators and then i selected
about a hundred of them to do profiles
everybody from the steam engine
going back to theodore judah who was
responsible for the transcontinental
railway really
moving up to google today so it's from
the steam engine to the search engine
with thomas edison the wright brothers
you've heard of and people you've never
heard of like samuel insult i'll bet you
hardly anybody has heard of samuel
insult yet to him we owe cheap
electricity
we've got to take a poll in the room and
see how many people in this room have
ever heard of sam insult we got one
two three
three out of this literate new york city
crowd that's pretty good too i'm very
surprised but there are other people who
are unknown i've included like gary
kildahl who's another one who gave us
the computer operating system
which was basically stolen by bill gates
not by by somebody associated
in seattle
and adapted and amended and killed all
innovation has been neglected
did you richard burkhauser ever work
here
no
you ever intern here at the strand yeah
no i just i just buy books here just buy
books how about harold evans when was
the first time you came to the strand
i came in this channel i was doing the
american century my book before this
which took me 12 years to write in about
15 years to research because i was also
at random house and i used to come in
this place is a treasure trove
there's nothing i like better in the
world haven't been a publisher of new
books there's nothing i like better than
the smell of old books it's like i was
getting a high every time i came in uh
and so i would sniff around the shelves
and i'd buy books i'd never heard of and
read them and see if they helped me to
understand what happened to america from
eighteen eighteen ninety nineteen
eighteen and i'm still in the library
where you can walk out with the books i
know well you could buy them
i mean you paid four dollars that was a
lot of money then
you can get it for four dollars today
you could probably get a complete
library shelf
we're here talking about books we have
an audience of new yorkers mostly and
we're going to get them at the
microphone here in a few minutes you
have a
question sir
uh yeah i have a question for mr
brookheiser and
pardon me if i'm not very good at this
but
um well i've lived in new york a long
time but uh
one time very long time ago
actually grew up in southern california
and i can remember
i can remember actually
like being the only person
in my third grade class who was for john
f kennedy
and likewise i remember barry goldwater
very well
and um although
i'm i was and in some respects still are
on the opposite side of the political
spectrum
um
i've observed something very strange
that has occurred maybe was going on
before post 11 but it's more obvious
after
9 11 which is i was
i was attending at union square during
the protests
and every anytime a republican came up
everyone got very excited and they all
wanted to go around it wasn't like there
was a lot of fighting it was like a
republican was very interesting and
everyone wanted you know to get their
point of view because obviously most
people at union square were not
supporting republicans
but so this one guy was very interesting
you know he was espousing the republican
view and he started going around saying
like well i'm a wilsonian democrat
and what i'm trying to get at is there
seems to be some kind of very strange
inversion that's going on
whereby
what i thought of as being the typical
republican line as i remembered it in
the old days from barry goldwater
notwithstanding vietnam but just
as as that the republicans represented
small government
decentralization
state authority
to some respects isolationism quote
unquote
and and non-intervention
and what seems to have happened
especially so post-9 11 is that now you
have
the republicans becoming the
quote-unquote wilsonian democrats the
interventionists
and you have
the um the democrats to some extent of
course there's always been a somewhat
progressive trend which is a little
isolationist in the democratic party but
it seems more pronounced if anyone has
seen the manifesto is quote put up by
robin williams
uh
in any case i i wonder if you have any
observation on that that the
republicans seem to have become
uh you know the the the now the the the
big uh
liberal democrats and
thank you
well look both of these parties have
been around for a long time uh
republicans for
almost 150 years in the democrats for
over 200
and um
you know big national parties cover a
lot of ground in a stretch of time like
that so you can go back in the history
of either party and find
strains of this or that
that's applicable now and that will
either surprise you or or gratify you so
i you know i
i'm not very excited by playing the game
of who's a wilsonian or who's a
hamiltonian now or who's a jeffersonian
i mean it just becomes label shifting i
i think the questioner was was
absolutely right that post 9 11
a lot of republicans have and
conservatives have
changed their attitudes about the third
world and there used to be a kind of
you know wash your hands of it attitude
um
you know these people are all in jams
that are of their own making and and
too bad you know we can't be bothered
with that well but we are bothered with
it you know we we were bothered with it
in 9 11. um the gentleman mentioned the
protests at union square uh just this
last week for the republican convention
uh and and i was there after 9 11 with
all the all the people you know
gathering in distress
after the trade towers were attacked and
destroyed
so
you know it's not possible it's not
possible to just avert one's eyes from
the third world
wave let me just tell our audience if
union square is just two blocks this way
in case you're not a new yorker harold
just a small commentary on that rich is
absolutely right of course because teddy
roosevelt was just as much an
interventionist the great period of
republican isolationism was in the 20s
but what we have now isn't in my
judgment sir a retail to wilsonian
democracy
because wilson for all his faults and
there were many also believed in
knitting alliances together and the
strand of isolationism in the republican
party today is preemptive war
because george bush didn't really try
and take a lot of allies along with him
i happen to be a supporter of tony blair
but there's still that strand of
fortress america america knows best in
the republican philosophy which isn't
shown in john berry john kerry was of
course accused of being french which is
the worst possible offense
question
yes hi mr evans my name is kate and um i
was wondering if you were to write a
history book over the last
four of the last four or five years
could you paraphrase what you might say
in that book
yeah i've got it uh of harold evans she
asked the question is if you were to
write a history book of the last five
years
you would paraphrase what he found
yeah what would you say about the last
five years of american history
well it's been very convulsive i think
there's been a struggle for american
identity i think the country
came together in total revulsion about
the islamic terrorists and i think after
that
the it's been less an argument to me
about how you respond to that than some
of the details for instance if you read
the 911 commission
it's now it's a fantastic document which
everybody must read
because this country was as i'll tell
you another book which is worth reading
steve carl's ghost wars and it traces
how we were asleep
largely through the
clinton years but also even more asleep
when george bush became president
because for nine months the signals were
even more dangerous and nothing was done
and it comes out clearly in the 911
report so i think i would entitle a
history of the last five years a fatal
complacency
take a shot at that well
you know the thing about surprise
attacks is that they they very often do
take you by surprise
franklin roosevelt was president
for nine years
in 1941 with pearl harbor
he knew japan was rearming
um in fact
he knew war was likely and and he
welcomed it
you know he thought japan was a problem
japan was doing horrible things in china
if you ever need a chinese
person
old enough to have remembered world war
ii which began in china in the 1930s
when japan invaded
i remember meeting such a man
in taiwan
my wife and i were taking a trip and he
was our guide that the government gave
us
and somehow japan
came up in the conversation and he said
they killed people like ants
you know this was this was not an
emotional man and it just sort of burst
out so roosevelt knew what was going on
in the world and he was um and he was
hoping to ready the country for war and
he had to overcome a lot of isolation of
sentiment
uh he thought the japanese were going to
strike at the dutch east indies
you know grab for the oil which they
also did but before they went there they
went to pearl harbor
so you know it's very easy to be wise
after the fact and you know i just wish
i just wish everybody in washington
could be as smart as everyone else says
they are we're going to put the numbers
on the screen so you can begin donning
if you want to join us by phone we'll be
here with our two guests for the next 25
30 minutes and a little background if
you don't know richard brookhiser by now
he's from rochester new york originally
a graduate of yale lives here in new
york city we said earlier has written
four books that we know of are there
others out there besides the george
washington john adams cuban dolores
governor morrison alexander hamilton
those are all the historical ones
and you still are a senior editor at the
national review that's right and a
columnist for the new york observer our
other guest harold evans
is among other things the author of the
american century in 1998 how'd that book
do
it was the best seller for many months
on the new york times and it's still
silly it's still silly
and you can probably find it here in the
strands you can certainly find here in
the style there'll be hills to play if
you can't studied years ago at the
university of chicago and stanford but
is originally from great britain married
to tina brown has two children how old
are those two kids uh george is 18 and
isabelle's 13 and they are both
omnivorous readers are they going to be
in in your business at all i doubt it i
think they've seen too much of the toil
and stress
yes sir
my name is david warren um i have a
civil ques first of all i'm a registered
republican and very fearful that george
bush actually might get reelected my
question is um george bush is trying to
clutter the constitution with gay
marriage amendment i think that's a very
dangerous
thing no matter how you feel about gay
marriage just the fact that he would
clutter the constitution with this it's
very threatening my second question is a
personal question to you uh how do you
feel about general joseph warren from
the revolution and my third thing is
more of a comment question is with oil
energy being such a precious resource
why aren't we spending more money on uh
roads for commuting bicycle lanes not
recreation bike lanes but commuting
bicycling to get around and other
alternative sources of energy investing
in tax breaks and things like that that
has not come to the forefront it's
always about oil rather than solar or
other types of energy or even
it's difficult in urban areas to get to
work by bicycle because we don't have
commuter bike lanes we have recreational
bike lanes and i wanted to get your
opinions on that all right we'll spread
some of that around here among our
guests you want to take on the gay
marriage uh i'll start it in reverse
order as far as bicycles go
uh some commutes in this country are
just very long they're really too long
for bicycles
um
you know i i don't face that i live on
16th street and national reviews on 30
between 32nd and 33rd street so you know
i can just walk if the weather is nice
but you know most people or a lot of
people who are driving an hour driving
two hours or taking a train of a similar
distance if they have to do that on a
bicycle that either becomes extremely
onerous or impossible
joseph warren
a very
brave interesting person
when we talk about the founding fathers
we talk almost always about the ones who
survived the revolution
you know because they're the ones who
accomplished things in the revolution
and then went on to have later careers
people like like washington jefferson
adams hamilton joseph warren didn't
survive the revolution he died at the
battle of bunker hill
he put his money where his mouth was he
put the declaration of independence says
would say because he died before it was
signed it would say we pledge our lives
our fortunes our sacred honor while he
gave his life
and uh it's a very moving story what
about um the whole issue of gay marriage
do you have a
view of that
i tell you what it's a matter of supreme
indifference to me i mean if people want
to live together i i just believe in
people living their own lives i got
married in the church i hope my children
will but i don't want to interfere in
other people's lives anyway whatsoever
i'm a libertarian on that earlier you
mentioned the supporter of tony blair
did you support tony blair's active
support of this country in going into
iraq yeah because i believe what i was
told
i did i believe what i was told
and i thought john kerry made a terrible
mistake when he said he would still have
done it because i wouldn't still have
done it
if i'd known
i would have taken longer to get the
allies together i would have cleaned up
afghanistan where the taliban is still
active that appalling bunch of thugs you
know
and i would have moved more deliberately
and taken more people with us you'd
never get the french possibly but even
so i supported tony blair and i still do
and in fact in southern iraq they're
having rather more success than there is
in central and northern iraq
if you've just joined us we're at the
strand bookstore at the corner of 12th
and broadway in new york city and we're
here just to talk with some
interesting folks about books about
politics about both from time to time
and we have people here in the audience
that are going to ask questions and say
some things but let's take a call next
from brooklyn new york our first call
for this segment go ahead brooklyn
you're on the air yes thanks for taking
my call i was particularly interested in
the remark i made about roosevelt and
his aware his awareness of the attack on
pearl harbor my understanding is he was
more than aware of the attack uh in
general terms but he understood that
attack was imminent that is to say
within 72 hours we had broken the
japanese code
messages were going out to uh bases um
uh united states bases
and um
even though we knew were going to be
attacked imminently not uh within three
months or four months but were
given
the fact that we had the cold broken
indications were
that
we were going to be attacked within 72
hours he knew that and he still couldn't
prevent no
it's not quite correct if you don't mind
i've examined all the details of this
alleged
roosevelt conspiracy to get us into
world war ii
with the connivance of winston churchill
it does not stand up if you look at my
research in the american century i've
taken it hour by hour minute by minute
rules that my real criticism of
roosevelt's not the one that richard
made my criticism is that when hitler
marched into the rhineland in 1936 in
breach of treaties with america in
breach of the lucano pact
america didn't even protest at that
moment we could have blown hitler away
with one strong breath what did fdr do
he went fishing now the gloss on it is
he was trying to school people
to get ready to go to war and i think
richard's right there but i do not
accept sir the implication either from
you or for richard that somehow or other
roosevelt was complicit in allowing the
japanese to it doesn't stand up to that
no no harry i i was not saying that i
you know and the notion that we've
broken the codes and we knew the
japanese ships were coming that's
michael moore in 1941 i mean that's just
absolutely bonkers
grassy knoll conspiracy theory good bs
what what roosevelt i mean roosevelt was
aware of the general strategic situation
and he saw that like like two tectonic
plates the united states and japan were
gonna were going to come into conflict
that's all i was saying i agree with
that let me take a call from miami
you're on miami go ahead please yes i
have a question for both of the both of
the analysts or authors i'm sorry
um used to be when you were growing up
you know you just
couldn't wait i'm 45 now and it's like
you couldn't wait
so that you could travel and see things
but
as things exist now it's like if you
want to trip around the world you would
rather take the money because
you know it's just terrible to think
about the thought of traveling and i
have to
bow down as an american i just want to
know what your
contestants or your artists thought
about that richard kaiser i'm planning
to go to argentina and brazil in
november after this hamilton show goes
up i want to go to two countries where
they've never heard of alexander
hamilton i want to talk to you about
alexander hamill in a moment what about
you and traveling oh well i used to edit
content as traveller magazine so i will
call them up and say where's the nice
place where i can't hear a single word
about half the things i've been hearing
if you have any fear of traveling at all
not at all no i think airline security
is obviously improved and you cannot let
your life be run by these hooligans
these radical islamists i went up to the
new york society the historical society
to see that hamilton exhibit and they
said not open until september the 11th
september 10th excuse me september 10
however the two pistols are there to see
right now and they have life-size
statues of hamilton and burr who seem to
me to be very small compared to this is
the biggest show on hamilton that's ever
been done we've got our consultant
i'm the historian curator
but it's just terrific stuff we have we
have a copy of the first letter he ever
wrote when he was 12 years old living in
the caribbean
we've got
paintings of him of his friends of his
enemies of everybody in this world and
then what you saw is
is in a way the climax it is the the
actual pistols that were used in the
hamilton bird duel
and we commissioned the sculptor to make
two life-sized bronze statues of
hamilton and burr and they will be
standing there you know in the duelists
position with their pistols raised and
you notice they seem small and
and i did have that reaction even though
i know what their heights were they were
five six both men were five six and and
hamilton certainly was very slight
but when i first saw the statues i
thought maybe the sculptors screwed up
they looked they look like kids but what
it is
is they are on the floor these are
statues on the floor are level and you
never see statuary at our level it's
always up it's always on a pedestal and
if you go to union square where there's
a lincoln lafayette washington you
measure those statues i bet they are
larger than life-size
and so this is a readjustment to see a
statue that's an actual life-sized just
wanted to say on alexander hamilton
because totally fascinating richard's
book is really fantastically interesting
i don't think many people realize just
how important hamilton was from what i
described in they made america because
he created in a sense the modern america
of industry and banking we owe it to
hamilton not to jefferson not to
washington not to even adam's none of
them we owe it to hamilton hamilton was
one of the few people who understood it
right you know if you read jefferson's
and adams's wonderful letters to each
other's old men whenever they took banks
come up it's like as republicans usually
can't you know it's like it's
frightening how much they don't
gotta get a quick answer to a question
because i couldn't get it at the
historical society those statues were
commissioned just for this different
just for the show thank you
your question ma'am your name please yes
my name is maria teron i am
a physician from syria
a question to either of the historians
where do you put democracy in america
right now
comparison to other periods of the
american history and another question is
i was watching the gop on c-span and i
was wondering um how could they ask for
the support for american people since
they did not defend them the first time
and how could this happen
in a democracy
her first question uh harold evans was
democracy in america today tell me if
i'm wrong how does it compare with
previous years
well it's uh
you know it's don't get too gloomy about
it because when i began the american
century uh very few people could vote
blacks couldn't vote women couldn't vote
the sad thing about democracy in america
is that
when
very few people could vote
a hundred years ago
eighty percent of those who could vote
did
today when there's
pretty well universal suffrage despite
errors so few people vote so in fact
only fifty two or 3 percent vote in a
presidential and eve if you look at the
congressional local races it's totally
appalling i would prefer the australian
system
uh that you you uh it affects your
taxation
if you don't vote
are you a citizen yes
yes i i asked carol evans who says and
he said yes your second question i'll
let richard brookheiser answer it give
it to us again yeah
i was watching the
republican convention and i was uh all
the time wondering how would they stand
up and say elect us elect us
after four years of their failing to
protect the american people
a very
a nice great historian forest mcdonald
he's one of my favorite historians and
he's a wonderful guy
and he has a very dark streak
he wrote a book on the presidency the
history of the presidency and one of the
questions he took up was why does
presidential popularity go up and down
and he gave various scholarly opinions
it has to do with the economy it has to
do with this has to do with that and he
shot them all down he said you know no
no model holds up except for one
he said the one case in which the
popularity of the president always goes
up is when there's been some unignorable
disaster in foreign affairs
waynesville north carolina next call go
ahead please
my wife
my wife and i just enjoy your show very
much and i'd like to make an observation
a comment and a question
my observation is is that my wife keep
it down
my wife and i have noticed recently that
we found the communist manifesto in a
lot of the bookstores
where you've never seen it before
and
to go to my comment yes we have been
attacked since 9 11 but i i would think
that there's another attack that
americans
blue collar workers are experiencing
right now
that uh nafta
uh the chinese uh looming uh uh with
their 64 cents an hour jobs uh the
corruption on wall street
and blue collar workers are being told
just be thankful you've got a job my
question to the panel is is do they
believe that uh publishers and authors
will be turning to the plight of the
american worker
harold evans we'll be returning to what
was that whether politicians will be
turning to the plight of the american
worker well i think uh
both parties pretend to do that i mean
for my money john kerry is more focused
on that because he's attacking an
incumbent when there's been a loss of so
many jobs so in a sense he has a easier
how to row but i don't pretend that it's
easy
to recover the prosperity and the jobs
as you rightly say for the blue-collar
worker because the world has changed and
the imperative it seems to me
is to speed up and accelerate the
education for the information age and
secondly to prolong unemployment pay
which was cut too short i think by the
bush administration to give people a
chance to transfer from one area to
another
mr brookhausen
i i think the caller was um
he was focusing on the loss
jobs being lost
to foreign
competition and
i don't think they're going to be many
books on that frankly and i i was very
struck years ago i was on a panel
uh and one of one of the other panelists
was a man from abc
and he said the two issues that i worry
about my reporters
all agreeing on
are abortion and free trade
they're all for abortion they're all for
free trade and i think that's uh the
free trade part of it is true of
my class
the verbalist class
um you know and i i'm i'm just answering
this as to how likely are there gonna is
it gonna be to get books on this topic i
think not very tucson arizona good
afternoon hello you're on the air
hi yes um i think it's very fascinating
that i'm on the show because i'm not a
person that would usually call
in
and
and in fact that you're speaking of
hamilton is very terrific and i remember
as a child my father he gave me a book
on
burr and this really led to me
uh being really fascinated about this
and and i would like to go back just to
say one other thing uh this other person
stood up and said he was afraid of bush
being re-elected i'm afraid of kerry
being reelected i mean i'm very afraid i
changed to a republican this year from
the independent
and um thank you and thank you richard
for writing such a great book that's
going to come out let me ask our two
guests here if they're afraid of either
man being elected
i'm not afraid of of either man i mean
i'm going to vote for george bush
but i think the terror war is going to
last for 30 years and there will have to
be republicans and democratic presidents
during the whole course of it just as a
cold war you're not afraid of john kerry
well i i don't think john kerry is the
person i'd pick to to start with the
democrat running the cold war but am i
afraid of it no i'm not afraid are you
mr evans afraid of either man
not really but i wish the bush
administration had been more competent
in the excuse execution in iraq now we
have western iraq we have an enclave of
terrorists not being cleaned up osama
nobody mentioned osama osama and his mob
of hooligans killers
are still there in afghanistan
i'm worried about competence i was
worried about competence when i read
richard clark's book i was even more
worried about competence when i read the
9 11 report so though i don't share many
of the paranoia
[Applause]
i do think the question the republican
administration is to answer isn't
courage
the big sea of courage we're all
courageous it's the small sea of
competence
well look that's true look how many
look how many generals lincoln had to go
through before he found grant
that's true
mcclellan hooker
mead i mean they were just they were
just all screwing up well if they'd
listened if they hadn't fired chareski
and put more troops into iraq they've
been in a better position now that's a
strange
position if you're a pacifist you'd
rather didn't put more troops in it was
just when when don rumsfeld said looting
that's what free societies are about
that lost me that lost me totally we are
at the strand bookstore in new york city
and we'll be here for about another hour
and 22 minutes in 22 minutes at the top
of the hour john fun to the wall street
journal and amy goodman of democracy now
will be here to do the same thing our
two guests
are doing at this moment we have a
question from the audience yes sir yeah
hi um is this i don't know it's just the
ride
we can't hear you would you speak up
please yeah the microphone you'll get
very close to the microphone the
microphone does not is not amplified
therefore well we just dropped let me
take a call let's go next to oak ridge
tennessee oak ridge you're on the air
we'll come back to you go ahead oak
ridge
hi i'm amy barnes
i had a kind of a broader question about
integrity or the lack thereof in
american history do you think that um
that
we've gotten in trouble and integrity
has always risen to the top and got us
out of trouble or has the american
system always managed to survive uh the
general lack of integrity
mr evans you're on camera i didn't quite
get it
she's talking about integrity first of
all just let me just broaden the
question uh are people in leadership
today in this country do they have
integrity i think they do actually are
you know all political leaders
have stresses and strains secrets and
challenges they can't face i'm
integrity as i've said previously isn't
what bothers me i think i mean i believe
george bush believed what he was told
about
afghanistan and iraq and i'm sure that
john kerry had integrity on that boat
more integrity than the people who were
taking snaps
shots of him he would never within a
million miles of a rifle fire
integrity is competence that bothers me
i think that uh
you can be have tremendous integrity and
be totally
dumb richard brookhiser integrity what's
the level we have now
the the questioner
framed it very interestingly because she
said is the american system able to with
unders to to withstand
lacks of integrity when they crop up and
i think that is precisely what the
founders intended it to do
they wanted to build something that was
firm enough that it could um
you know stand in all kinds of stresses
and strains uh including the appearance
of
of robes or
or
hairy of of dummies people can't do the
job
and um you know you can find you can
find bad performance in the most
unexpected places
two of our most brilliant presidents
were jefferson and madison and without
question
i think jefferson was only a half good
president i think madison was a terrible
president exactly and their policies
issued in the war of 1812
when i mean they thought madison thought
um
you know when that war was declared we
we would just take canada in a few weeks
i think buzzwords up there and take it
and then the british end up you know
burning washington and burning the white
house i think that's very good answer by
rich i'd just like to reinforce it by
saying we the american system has come
through so many crises
if you think back you know vietnam
watergate this that will want to and at
the moment in the foreground these
crises always look bad and the people
seem to lack integrity i think the
american political system is the most
resilient in the world actually if i i
want to ask you the question give you a
moment to think about it the book you
would recommend to someone pick a young
person or an older person who hasn't
read much one book that you'd recommend
that they read
that might give them some insight to
something
hold on for anything at all
no no advertising that's what i'm
getting at probably history pick a
history book of some kind uh yes sir
would you try again
uh can you hear me this time you have to
speak up a little bit because there's no
amplification okay yeah hi
yeah actually uh you you just brought up
jefferson and actually uh
that's a good segue because uh when i
was in college we had a statue of
jefferson actually we have a statue of
alexander hamilton as well but a group
of a group of students
we were all very much opposed to the
idea of having a statue of thomas
jefferson and our tuition going to to
pay for the upkeep of a statue of a
person who would
his ideas on
you know non-white people being
sub-human were very well documented and
i'm sure he would have preferred that
none of us were there
and anyway i i guess my question
and so so anyway i wrote an op-ed about
it and
in the college paper and there was a
i got a lot of angry response there
people who supported as well but i guess
my question is is this
i noticed like with a lot of european
leaders leaders in european history who
had very strong stances
regarding bigotry of certain people
whether it be armenians or gypsies or
jews or whoever
their bigotries and their policies
regarding those bigotries often
today overshadow the rest of their
political careers
whereas in america andrew jackson for
example who was responsible for the
deaths of roughly half of the cherokee
nation is still you know on our bills
you know what what's your university i
went to columbia let me ask them because
we're running out of time to respond to
what you just said
well
you know i'm a hamilton partisan but i'm
not going to take the easy shot at
jefferson what you say is absolutely
right if you read his notes on virginia
you know what he says about black people
i mean it's
it curls your hair to read it i think
with jefferson
what i keep coming back to is that he
always believed and he never you know
until he died in his eighties he never
gave up on the belief
that whatever he thought about the
inferiority of of different races and in
whatever capacities he always insisted
that they should have equal rights
and even though he was a slave owner all
his life
he never stopped thinking that slavery
was wrong
that was that was a change that happened
that was a change that happened in the
generation after him people like john
calhoun come along and they say no
slavery is not wrong slavery is good
slavery has excellent qualities now
that's not obviously i think someone
like hamilton who helped found the new
york manumission society in this state
which was a slave state
at the time of independence and and the
reason it stopped being a slave state is
because people like hamilton and john
jay and others formed a society which
said this is bad we have to work to get
rid of this and it took a long time but
they did it they made the decision and
they made the effort you know and
hamilton also did not think that blacks
were inferior he was very ahead of his
his time for a white man in in having
those beliefs so i think he's better
than jefferson uh is jefferson the worst
you can get no humanity can give you a
lot worse than jefferson give us 30
seconds of your thoughts i know you have
something to say yeah
jefferson owned slaves like including
his own children so i mean to me if he
didn't believe if he believed in equal
rights which is a difficult concept to
swallow but if he believed in equal
rights to me that makes it even more
you know horrendous
you know owning people you know
including his own kids i mean that's
harold evans you want to jump in here
well just as very if you read the good
biography of lincoln it's interesting to
see where lincoln changed
i mean i get tired of this insistence on
a foolish consistency in people's
attitudes and lincoln's change from
being tolerant of slavery
which he was to being the great
emancipator which he was is i think a
fascinating progression and i'd like to
tie that answer
to a book i think if you're going to
read a single book a really good
biography of lincoln would be this thing
i would recommend
anybody to read although washington's by
richard brooke is a marvelous book too
but i think lincoln's changing character
and the resolution and nobility of
lincoln and by god talk about politics
what he had to put up with in terms of
abuse from the opposition today
what would be your book richard brooke
kaiser uh this is the last book i read
or the second last book i read the
rodetsky march by joseph roth it's a
novel about the end of the
austro-hungarian empire
and it's just a very wise novel about
about politics uh and um about things
going bad in politics let's go next to
syracuse new york here on the air
syracuse hello hi uh my name is uh sue
um and i just to change the subject a
little bit from what you were just
talking about i had to call in response
to a comment that was made earlier by
your guests one of them i believe said
something to the effect that the
reporters are for choice and for free
trade and that you weren't going to be
getting many books in the way of looking
at the loss of jobs secondary to trade
sir i beg to differ
i'm really surprised that somebody
didn't mention the book that just came
out by lou dobbs called exporting
america
an excellent book and all the more
excellent because
it came from someone that one might have
described as one of the guards quote
unquote and according howard zinn and
the revolt of the guards
um there are a lot of books out there in
the loss of jobs they're not all just
coming from the radical left they're
beginning to come from mainstream
america
and i'm just
thinking that the booksellers should be
even more if it's in fact true that the
reporters
are for free trade that it's incumbent
even more upon booksellers to start
putting those books out there so that we
can see them and read about them
um
it's
it's both parties in fact are for free
trade and yet i would i would
venture to say at the realistic of
someone jumping down my throat
that more people in this country's lives
are going to be adversely affected
by the loss of jobs um by the the
fallout from free trade then are ever
going to be adversely affected by
terrorist attacks from osama bin laden
thank you syracuse
let me ask the two of you about
something she just said in the middle of
all that that book sellers ought to be
putting these books out in other words
putting them in a location people can
find them the question of both of you do
booksellers have the power from your
experience at random house
to move books
and do they move books based on the
amount of money that people from random
house are giving them to put them on the
end caps and all that kind of yeah well
the question of course before the book
seller is a writer
and we have to have inspired writers to
advance the point of view she's taking
because most economic economists are not
for that point of view as you know
so you have to get the writer first then
the bookseller
can put something out and the book
seller certainly can influence he can
put it right at the front of the store
but normally the publisher has to pay
for that
nancy and fred bash here do they have
the power to move books by where they
put them on the tables down downstairs
or up here brian i'm going to answer an
earlier question because i'm still
thinking about it how many people here
own slaves
how many people in this room own slaves
the answer is no one owns slaves
so it's very easy for all of you and all
of us
to say wasn't that an awful thing
because that's a vice that's gone
okay
it's harder for us
to look at vices or to think about vices
that may be ongoing
that may be things that we do
or that may be things that we collude in
and slavery was a curse on this country
governor morris said it was the curse of
heaven
on any state or colony that had it
and he was absolutely right but i urge
all of us
to
not preen
so much
when we read about this period
you know and and pat ourselves on the
back that well oh i don't own slaves so
therefore i must be better than
jefferson right
yes sir your name
yeah hi my name is ivan orgenblick
uh and i have a question about books
that
that's what this is all about books
uh was there a book written
to tell us the real theory of why iraq
was was uh
was there a book written to tell us why
iraq was invaded in your opinion oh yes
uh there is a
there's a tv film called iraq which
unfortunately warner has just refused to
put out which is testimony by officials
i don't know whether rich had seen it
i think the best thing i can recommend
and i think everybody should buy it is
the 911 commission
which is a work of great lucidity and
the new york review of books has got a
marvelous essay on
the night the 911 took evidence for
everybody pretty well
they took it from the duo of bush and
cheney because the president wouldn't
appear by himself anyway 911 report is
well worth reading about and it goes
into the reasons for invading iraq
for and against the evidence i think
it's pretty impressive piece of work
i i think there are books out there i
think there are a lot of books and i
think booksellers have gotten a lot
better about having a variety of them
than there were 25 years ago i mean 25
years ago when you went to a bookstore
you'd see like a huge pyramid of you
know dianetics or or whatever was like
some big selling book and the notion was
to get people in the stores we have to
have this big pile of a best seller and
then the booksellers have figured out no
the way to get people in the stores is
to make the book store as much like a
library you know you want the people to
stay you want people to spend time and
if they do that they'll leave with one
or two or three books strand will tell
you i believe i saw the statistics that
twenty percent of their books are sold
on the internet not even here in the
stores which changes a lot uh could we
have can i ask one more question uh
let's let the gentleman behind you
because we're running out of time thank
you but we want to get everybody
involved here
we're going to finish your thought ahead
please okay i'd like to ask the uh yale
man if he has any skull and bone stories
is there are they any more than just a
social club
were you a member of scotland well if i
were i'd have to leave the room
no i wasn't um
i think skull and bones is
was
freemasonry for kids
that's how that's how it got founded you
know
you know people have been to germany
they'd seen sort of german student clubs
and freemasonry in the early 19th
century and they thought you know wow
this is cool let's let's do it here at
yale and um
you know it's it's we we have we have
these two skull bones men running for
president in case in case anyone doesn't
doesn't know
but uh so uh so yale being um an
institution with a lot of elite uh
students in it or people from you know
wealthy powerful families
uh some of that is has has rubbed off on
this um
society richard brookheiser thank you
for joining us today and before we lose
our other guests you brought several co
i know you have some connection with
this or you would not i made it to at
lunch
and what is it this is a magazine i
brought copies of people to seek away
it's a a brilliant summary every week
which you won't read anywhere else
because it's totally non-partisan of
what's going on in the world and i've
the three copies there for at least 12
people it's great fun i really really
thank you very much we'll be back with
amy goodman and john fun in just a
moment amy roach is the producer of this
program tom aldridge the director and
connie debley is somewhere in the strand
bookstore with i think a very familiar
face yes i am brian you have to come
back down to the first floor which is
where all the activity is today and
you're going to see a person who spends
a lot of time here and has had been here
a lot of years nat hentoff hello mr
handoff hello what's your history with
this bookstore oh my when i first came
to new york in 1953 the two places i
first went to
was the commodore music shop because
that's where the jazz players
congregated and of course strand i knew
it by legend
and
after all
the years my son nicholas worked here
for uh fred's father benjamin bass in
the rare book department he's now a
criminal defense and civil liberties
lawyer in arizona and a book collector
and i never come here
like today without buying a couple of
books well before we get into the
political books tell us what you're
going to buy well this is i wanted to
have two copies of this the single best
book on the
i think the most original composer in
american history duke ellington it's
simply a collection of oral histories by
people who worked with dude and this
is there was once a world it's a 900
year history of a staple
of a jewish town
in the old country before they were then
massacred
and so you just found these roaming
around right yeah
well that you know the serentivity of a
place like this
is wonderful
i did research for my book the war on
the bill of rights
largely in stores here and other places
what do they call them in the
automobiles right now pre-owned books
and
iranic i was wondering i was very much
involved with committees of
correspondence that samuel adams started
in boston
which let the people all over the
colonies know about what was happening
to their liberties and their property
from the british
and i found a book a biography of
patrick henry
and i was looking in the index
committees of correspondence and i found
out and i didn't know it anywhere else
that thomas jefferson
in 1773
had a secret meeting in the
raleigh book store not a bookstore a
tavern the raleigh tavern in
williamsburg he knew what sam adams was
doing and he said to patrick henry and
richard henry lee we ought to do one of
those
and it's a part of the book because
there are now 340
cities and towns around the country and
four states that see alaska hawaii
vermont and maine where the legislatures
or and the city councils have passed
bill of rights defense resolutions
which tell them the congressman from
those areas we're looking at you to do
something about ash crowd what ashcroft
has done to the constitution and it's
working because in the house and senate
now there's more resistance not only
among liberals but among conservative
libertarians and it's all because of the
internet which has taken up the legacy
of committees of correspondence let me
ask you about this area right here which
is all political books yes indeed what
do you think of them well earlier today
i heard several of the guests talking
about the current stream of political
books
as being
well essentially pamphlets polemics
and i agree most of it because i'm
willing to bet i won't be here then but
future historians i think will have only
a footnote if that for al franken or ann
coulter
but there are a few substantial books
one of the most important is coming out
pretty soon
published by w w norton that released
the
9 11 commission
this is called powerless times it's a
history of free speech in america
from 1798
when under john adams
the alien and sedition acts put
americans in prison only seven years
after the first amendment was ratified
for putting congress or the president in
ridicule that's not hard to do
it goes from 1798 to the present war on
terror it's by jeffrey
stone a professor of constitutional law
at the university of chicago and i'm
very interested to see whether it will
get one-tenth of the attention and the
sales
of franken or coulter because it doesn't
have lies lies lies in the
title i so you think the title is really
important in these apparently so
how long have you been a columnist for
the village voice i started there in
1958
and it was the first so-called of the
alternative newspapers and we still run
stories that the so-called mainstream
media does not now
we're in the village
for a person who's never been to to
greenwich village
explain to us what makes this area tick
what is it well there was a book i just
bought upstairs except nancy bass gave
it to me
it's a guide to new york including the
village by a british guy and he said the
thing about new york city and this
includes the village is there's always a
sense of excitement of energy he said
and i never quite can understand what
it's about but it's there
i mean sure it's changed since i was
here it's changed from before then but
it's still a place where there is the
strand where there's the village
vanguard the oldest jazz room in the
country
and
such a
a mix of people that that's why lenny
bruce flourished here he was also busted
here this is not always a place of free
speech
is this as uh is greenwich village as
liberal as it once was you know the term
liberal has become so fractured and to
me transmogrified that i no longer call
myself a liberal my term for people of a
certain age they may understand it i'm
an fdr libertarian i believe in the
safety net
very either should be a basic income
basic housing but also there ought to be
as both ronald reagan and william o
douglas said the government should be
off our backs when it comes to
regulating us
so
liberals
i don't know that's the problem with the
democratic party now so have you changed
your opinion or or is it the title that
bothers you i've changed i left the
democratic party for example i was a
lifelong democrat when bill clinton was
nominated for president i spent about
eight months in his record as governor
of arkansas i knew he could not his word
is not worth anything
and now we have
i mean look look at what's happening
with the swift vote veterans
on both sides there are deficiencies in
accuracy etc but the main problem and
hardly anybody mentions this except for
a very good reporter on the washington
post michael dobbs two sundays ago he
had a front page story in which he asked
the key question
and carrie could clear all of this up
he filed a freedom of information act
request with the navy to get john
kerry's records of those four months in
vietnam he got
six pages and he was told there were
more than 100 pages which carey will not
release
and on the same program at the same
article he talked about douglas
brinkley's book on carrick
brinkley had
access to carrie's diaries and papers in
vietnam
and everybody on the you know they carry
people have been saying all over
television everything is on the website
the records the diaries and the journals
are not there and they say well that's
an exclusive agreement with brinkley
brinkley has said since then often hey
that's his property anybody can have
anything in there it's up to him to
release it now this is hardly part of
the 24-hour news cycle matt handtop's
column sweet land of liberty can be read
in the washington times
that's a column i write separately from
the voice right it's part of the united
media it's a newspaper syndicate it goes
to about 250 papers they don't take it
every week but and the washington paper
because i was used to be at the
washington post when meg greenfield was
there but now i'm on the washington
times and i'm glad because i understand
that's the paper the white house reads
george bush may not read newspapers but
they read it there
and finally you have mentioned music
several times so we want to show our
viewers your the book before this this
new one that's coming out this month on
american music right that's a book about
jazz
country music folk music because it's
all intertwined
i'm thinking of writing a book about
jazz and the constitution
because max roach the drummer once said
and it stated in my mind jazz is like
the exemplification of constitutional
democracy collective improvisation with
individual voices who have to be
attentive to each other and then the
whole becomes
our constitutional democracy how old are
you not henta i am about to be 80. and
how long are you going to keep writing
as long as i can listen to jazz
thank you very much for coming over to
the strand you didn't have far to come
you live right in this neighborhood two
to two blocks away and these are the
books uh that he has uh coming out as we
mentioned before the war uh on the bill
of rights we'll show it one more time
the gathering resistance
and the gathering i'm the one journalist
i'm told that john ashcroft will not
allow to be interviewed by
thank you for coming over thank you and
from the first floor we go back up to
the second floor with brian and his uh
new
connie we have two very strong minded
and strongly opinionated people here we
planned it this way as our last hour of
our stay here at the strand i want to
start with amy goodman because i know
she's been driving all night to get here
and we have her ratty copy of her
her book called this is the one she
carries whether the exception uh to the
rulers
what were you able to do with this book
that you can't do with either your radio
show or your television stuff well i
think most importantly is reach new
audiences people who read books around
the country uh reaching uh in different
ways than democracy now which is the
radio and tv show that we do and i have
to say the response has been absolutely
incredible and that's response from
across the political spectrum we were
recently in tampa bay uh we're on the
exception to the rulers book and media
tour celebrating media that is the
exception to the rulers there it was
wmnf the community radio station and
speak up tampa bay which is the public
access tv station but also tampa's the
home of centcom mcdill military base
they we went to the tampa bay performing
arts center 2400 people came out sold
out and it's been the case around the
country because i think
that weapons of mass destruction not
finding it
exposed more than the bush
administration it exposed a media that
acted as a conveyor belt for the lies of
the administration and people across
people across the political spectrum are
sick of it they want independent media
and i think that's why the book despite
lack of corporate network coverage has
become a national bestseller john fun it
sounds like you got all your friends
here in one room this afternoon
absolutely uh well i'm a customer of
strand so they know me well tell tell us
about this book what do you want to do
with this book you can't do with your
columns
well
florida 2000 which was the 36 day
nightmare that we lived through i think
was as much a dividing line in how we
view elections as 911 was and how we
view homeland security because right now
one out of six americans tells john
zogby the pollster that they either
don't think their ballots will be
counted accurately this fall or they're
not sure they'll be counted accurately
that's a level of cynicism and anger
about the electoral process which is
toxic for our democracy forty four
percent of americans think we could have
another florida style situation i think
it could be even worse if this election
is as close as two thousand
you had all the lawyers congregate in
one state last time well the forest is
just as dry as it was in 2000 but now
everybody has matches every close state
could see a florida style election
litigation so
i don't want this to be a close election
i want to clear a winner regardless of
who that is and
it's very important if we have a close
election that we think about how angry
we're going to be before that taking
some precautionary measures to try to
forestall some of the worst consequences
because i am telling you if this country
goes through another disputed election i
think it could leave some real damage
one of the things we've talked about all
afternoon long periodically is fox news
how do you explain you're they're way on
the other side of you how do you explain
the success of fox news at this
republican convention
i think
the real story of this convention is not
what happened inside but what happened
outside and i have heard almost none of
the networks talk about in a regular way
the historic nature of the protests that
took place outside and this includes the
discussion about fox you saw last sunday
the largest political demonstration in
the history of political conventions in
this country on tuesday a day of direct
action the largest mass arrest over a
thousand people in this city's history
and one of the largest in this country's
history we're talking about a week of
overwhelmingly
peaceful non-violent protest of people
and again i would say across the
political spectrum interviewing people
like a man a republican from orange
county who flew in for these protests
who said that he considers himself a
conservative republican but that he does
not consider war crimes a conservative
issue he'd rather he does not consider
war crimes conservative he says he
considers himself a conservative but he
doesn't consider an out-of-control war
budget a conservative value and he went
on from there
we saw
levels of organizing in this city and
anger about what was taking place
outside of course more people than were
inside and the real story here is how
the media almost entirely
left it out
and yet you had more people outside than
inside sure they'd mention protests
in the traffic reports for example
where to avoid in new york city no
protest is not a traffic report protest
is a story of descent that makes this
country healthy and we need a media and
that includes um the critique not only
of fox news but abc nbc cbs cnn that
went to the streets in the same way cnn
followed delegates from their hometown
to new york they did little sort of
postage stamp stories which were very
nice you know why does someone come here
where do they come from what is their
community what about the protesters
hundreds of thousands of protesters why
didn't we see the same level of coverage
why people prepare to leave their homes
and come to voice their dissent and i
will say not only against the bush
agenda
but it's a strong message to john kerry
about what people want to see him
addressing
well
i have some bad news for people who
thought the protesters should have
gotten more coverage because given how
television operates
which is the maxim if it bleeds it leads
the only way the protesters are going to
get significantly more coverages if they
had been mass violence in the streets
and i don't think that would have been
particularly good for the protesters
cause or for the city or for the
delegates but john do you think that's
right don't you think that okay i i'm
here today to talk about what is and
what is is the following just because
you have a bunch of protesters in the
streets
is significant
look
well i can i can see i'm going to bring
my own heckling section with me
free free speech only goes so far
uh
that's right
why don't uh let me just suggest that
those of you who are very strongly
partisan this
let john fund have his say let amy have
her say and then we'll all go home
having been educated by both sides
the the clapping routine is fine i don't
really care but it we don't we're not
going to gain anything because most of
you in this room are on amy's side we
understand that's fine but we want to
try to have a discussion let john have a
say
thanks i appreciate it and i like you
too
uh
the protesters are a significant force
but
most of the reporters that were here
were political reporters they're
covering an election
and just because there are a whole bunch
a big whole bunch of protesters in the
streets
doesn't necessarily translate into
national
political trends which move the election
i'll give you an example in 1968 this
country was convulsed by the vietnam war
we had assassinations of robert kennedy
assassinations of martin luther king
the democratic candidate hubert humphrey
who campaigned the last month of the
election as the peace candidate only got
43 of the vote 1972 the country was
convulsed by the vietnam war again we
had a peace candidate george mcgovern
who had enormous popular support among
young people and students and lots of
people who very much were opposed to the
vietnam war he got 37 percent of the
vote so just because you have a real
large bunch of protesters in the street
doesn't automatically mean that that is
going to have enormous national
political rights
what determines that first of all the
media is there to cover as you said what
is well there were hundreds of thousands
of people in the streets you talk about
a bunch or a large bunch of protesters
why not talk about the bunch of
delegates who are inside madison square
garden you wouldn't do that you would
say there was a large uh gathering of
people the republican national
convention but if the media doesn't
cover it i went back and took the
trouble to go back and see how much
coverage the protesters had in 1984 in
san francisco
when the democrats met and also in
dallas when the republicans met i've
gone back lots of conventions have had
significant protests now the only one
that got significant media coverage was
chicago which unfortunately descended
into violence but this is the whole
point that there is a evolving
peaceful non-violent mass movement in
this country that the corporate media
better start covering now i would say
let me just say something the networks
abc
nbc cbs they are using our airwaves they
are using a national treasure and they
have a responsibility to cover the
stories you want
to bring up the full diversity of views
across the political spectrum when you
say the stories i want we're just saying
cover what is do not ice out dissent amy
the great thing about modern technology
is
there is more opportunity for people to
find news that they consider significant
on an individual level than ever before
in 1980 when we had the reagan carter
election we had three broadcast networks
cnn was just barely starting we didn't
have the internet we had 40 talk radio
shows in the country now we have 1400 we
have an enormous array of periodicals
not just print but on the web
you can get any amount of information it
is an avalanche of information if you
want to get it now if you want to talk
about the networks you of all people
should know that the influence of the
networks declines every year in fact the
influence of the networks is shrinking
so much that some of the cable stations
beat them in the ratings of the
conventions during the democratic and
republican conventions the networks are
withdrawing from news on all fronts not
just coverage of protests but they're
shrinking their news operation and their
audiences are shrinking so don't be
obsessed by the old media you should be
a new media person we're talking about
all the media we're talking about not
only the project
the internet is completely non-corporate
i'm talking about what people have
access to in this country there is still
a major digital divide who gets access
to the internet and who doesn't i'm
talking about what are the numbers amy
tell us tell me what the digital divide
is because right now we're getting to
the point now where a hook up a hookup
for the internet is down to 6.95 a month
well just go up to the south bronx every
public library in the country has free
internet access that doesn't mean it's
and yes and libraries are closing
earlier and earlier every day it makes
it very difficult to get to the
important point is where most people get
their information is television let's
not talk percentages or anything let's
just talk about what is the result
of americans have cable television
that's good 83
public television corporate television
too i would say that all of the networks
and i'm including unfortunately pbs and
that let me give you an example
in the week the two weeks around general
colin powell giving his address at the
un his big push for war uh fairness and
accuracy and reporting fair.org did a
study of the four major nightly
newscasts cbs nbc abc and the pbs
newshour with jim lehrer the four major
nightly newscasts there were 393
interviews done around war this was the
critical period right at the beginning
of february 2003.
only three of almost 400 were with
anti-war representatives i don't even
think we can call that mainstream media
anymore it didn't represent mainstream
america where most people were opposed
to the invasion for more inspections and
diplomacy at the time that's an extreme
media and yet you have i'm not saying a
fringe minority or a silent majority a
silenced majority in this country
silenced by the corporate media that is
horrified what is taking place and the
media should be reporting that wall
street journal the new york times the
washington post just a couple of
questions
when congress voted the resolution to
authorize force in iraq
october
there was a majority against the war in
this country yes or no
i think the importance yes or no
yeah i would say no but no public
opinion poll agrees with you no wait
just no public opinion what i think now
let me ask you a second question the
question is what is the question that is
asked the critical point is what is the
information that people have at the time
what was being said at that time
we're all entitled their own opinions we
are not entitled to our own set of facts
the bottom line is regardless of what
people's opinion of iraq now is and
certainly a whole bunch of mistakes have
been made
many many mistakes in october 2002 when
congress was debating it the majority of
the american people wanted the vote for
the authorization of force now the media
covers political events
the training that they get as
journalists is not to abandon
objectivity completely and take sides to
embrace one cause or another whether
it's vegetarianism or environmentalism
or of opposition to a war
the reality was the democratic party is
largely to blame for this they're the
opposition party they control the united
states senate that means they control
the flow of debating the united states
senate now with the exception of howard
dean who was not in the congress and the
exception of dennis kucinich and al
sharpton with the exception of those
three all of the democratic candidates
for president supported the vote to
authorize force in iraq all of the
democratic leadership
of significance with the exception of
nancy pelosi voted to authorize use of
force in iraq
when the democrat the leadership excuse
me the leadership when when the debt
when the democratic party abandons its
anti-war position and some would say out
of colorado and some would say out of
political prudence although it didn't
help them much in the november 2002
election the media has to cover
the opposition the opposition
on the level of leadership had vanished
john that's why howard dean rose that's
why howard let me just respond so the
media is not necessarily going to give
equal time to people if 75 of the
democratic party in congress abandons
what you just said i agree with you over
the democratic party um abandoning the
anti-war position i agree with you that
in october of 2002 let us not forget
that john kerry and john edwards
authorized the
president to invade iraq they voted for
john kerry says he wouldn't change his
mind today exactly and so does john
edwards exactly there i agree with you
but the role of the media is not just to
reflect the very narrow spectrum and as
you point out sometimes no spectrum at
all between the republicans and the
democrats the media has to be broader
than just covering let me talk as you
talk the media must be larger than just
covering the difference in the power
elite often they agree and you've
pointed that out there is a majority in
this country that is not just
progressive that is conservative
conservative as well that deeply cares
about corporate control that cares about
issues of privacy that cares about
almost a thousand u.s service men and
women who have died in iraq a completely
out-of-control war budget billions of
dollars going to not small businesses to
shore them up but the massive bus the
mega corporations like halliburton and
bechdel yes most people in this country
feel that way and it's not liberal and
it's not conservative but you put your
finger on it it is not just about
covering the difference between the
democrats and republicans in fact most
of america has gone way beyond that and
it's our job not to cover what we wish
for but as you pointed out what is this
past week in new york what is was half a
million people in the streets of new
york a mass protest for a week where
almost 2 000 people were arrested why
didn't we see the level of coverage the
lazy reporters didn't even have to go
okay
first of all
i am i am supportive of a vastly
increased
spectrum political debate but i notice
that most of the people in this room for
the last few years haven't been
interested in helping the green party or
the ralph nader people or the
libertarian party get on the ballot
there seems to have been a polarization
around two major parties so if media
coverage follows the polarization around
two major parties that is unfortunately
describing what is now you your your
opinion
is very good for opinion journalism but
the vast tradition in this country is of
objectivity
journalists who supposedly just report
the facts now we can argue about whether
or not
periodicals or newspapers or tell
networks follow that but to expect
journalists to take sides when they're
supposed to just deliver the facts we're
just saying deliver the facts why not
cover what was happening outside we're
saying deliver the facts let the people
decide that's
that's a separate question i'm simply
saying you really want people
who are in the streets to have as big a
megaphone as the people in the hall now
that's a legitimate point of view
because if there's one criticism i have
of the current media structure it's not
so much ideological it is class based
that is if you have a suit if you go to
a certain school if you have a certain
background if you
if you're from a certain area then
you're probably much likely to end up on
television you're much likely to get
quoted you're much likely to end up on
the mcnero news hour you're much likely
to have credibility there are a lot of
people who i think have very valid
opinions who don't get on television
that's one of the great things about
c-span i think c-span offers more of a
spectrum of coverage for ordinary people
than almost any other network that's why
it's so valuable
but that is not the same thing as your
complaint your complaint is basically
saying my cause wasn't covered enough i
think that's a very narrow complaint i
think that you're completely
mischaracterizing what i've said i did
not say this is my cause i said that it
is you're not anti-war i said that we
are talking about are you pro-war why do
you just care about
are you pro-war and you just care about
coverage i'm not accusing you of that
one of the rules one of the rules of
life is if you answer a question with a
question
let me talk okay it is not you talking
and then attacking me in the midst of me
talking we're going to take turns here
yeah and you didn't answer my question
what is your question are you anti-war
oh i believe that what is happening in
iraq right now is a horror that is your
cause that's all are you pro-war john
i am convert i was always ambivalent
about the war in iraq i'm still somewhat
ambivalent about the war in iraq and
were you for the war in afghanistan yes
okay so you're pro-war now let's talk
about okay oh my goodness so let's talk
about what it what should be covered in
this past week and what should be
covered on a regular basis let's look
forward we need to go beyond and maybe
you agree in certain ways on this we
need to go beyond the democrats and the
republicans because um well john kerry i
think should take a very strong message
from what happened this week half a
million people in the streets on sunday
an overwhelmingly
peaceful protest i didn't see a lot of
john kerry signs i saw many many
anti-war signs and i think people are
extremely frustrated the democratic
party has made a calculation right now
they are going for that narrow group of
undecided voters that are very much
they're going for the bush base and
they're thinking if they can go further
and further to the right and they can
pull those people over
maybe they can eke out a victory i think
this is uh uh a losing calculation
because the fact is there is a majority
of people
in this country that is not being
addressed right now and they're going to
determine this election and they are let
me say who they are they are the people
who don't vote and those people have to
be galvanized have to be energized have
to feel like there is a difference and
if as you point out john kerry continues
along the line saying if i knew then
what i know now i would still authorize
the invasion then people don't feel like
there is very much of a difference john
kerry is going down a losing path right
now as evidenced by the percentage
let's be clear about one thing
your critique of the media is a critique
of societal political problems which go
much deeper because if you have a
political party like the democratic
party which can't recognize as you would
have it that there's a majority against
the war and they would vote for it if
they had a candidate that they could
support
then that is a clear systemic political
failure so your criticism shouldn't be
of the media it should be of the
democratic party because they're the
ones who have failed to pick up this
market opportunity that you've just
described because john they've nominated
two people john kerry and john edwards
who voted for the war still say they
would have voted to authorize war and i
went to their convention and i saw them
celebrate a war that is 35 years old
that they didn't support
the democrats back then didn't support
so this is truly bizarre they have
completely been co-opted by the position
that you oppose so your complaint is not
about the media it's about the
democratic party all right let amy
goodman have one last
minute comment and then we'll go to
questions oh i mean i think
the fact that for example there were two
major marches this week against the
media one was against fox and there were
thousands of people there uh protesting
uh what fox has done and the
obliterating of another point of view
and then the other one was a general
march on the media called march on the
media that was paper tiger and uh
fairness and accuracy and reporting and
others also thousands but they didn't
limit just they didn't just limit it to
fox they went from cbs to cnn to fox and
they're taking on the media because this
is not just about you should voice a
point of view anytime someone says bring
in another point of view that represents
a vast majority of people they're told
oh you just want your point of view
we're talking about the point of view of
a vast group of people in this country
whether or not they are represented by
the democratic and republican party in
this country because those are the
people john who are deciding whether to
vote it's not just the views of carrie
and bush
fox news is the only cable network i
know that puts on people from fairness
and accuracy in the reporting jeff cohen
among them fox news has as many liberals
as conservatives on its debate shows i
don't understand what you say when fox
news obliterates a point of view how can
you have obliterated point of view when
you have both sides arguing with each
other that's the essence of drama and
debate it's the essence of cable chat
shows a bunch of people from different
points of view argue how do they
obliterate a point of view
i don't even think you believe what you
say so why don't we
if you just tuned in we are at the
strand bookstore we're talking about
television not about books at the moment
we might get back to books uh before
this is over because these two people
have books out and we want to take a
question from somebody in the audience
go ahead and please give us your name
well let me just call myself
joe concerned citizen and i am a
partisan
i'm very partisan to to informed
enlightened
reality-oriented
democracy
that's why i'm standing here right now
now
let's get to what is
recently well in at least a few months
ago
an author named john prodos
who's a national security analyst
works with the national security archive
published a book
the title is
hoodwinked
now i've briefly scanned it
and the content is
he has taken
the recorded
statements from the administration
officials
uh
documents from
the um
well let me see here
joe we got to get to a question yeah
yeah okay
he's taken documents from the white
house and the national security
administration in washington uh there
are various bureaus and so forth he's
collected this
hard
factual
evidence
about what
about the reasons the causes for going
to war in iraq
and your position on iraq it's not my
position
it's what the hard core
evidence
but what is your position obviously
you're motivated for a reason why are
you why are you so motivated it's not an
opinion
it's a fact what fact
the bush administration
lied to everyone
about the causes to going into a war
that we know have
have cost the taxpayer
right now
150 billion dollars
almost a thousand lives
has wrecked
our relations with uh former allies
has cost iraqis at least 10 000 lives
at least three times that number have
been named mutilated in their lives
ruined the fact of the rea of the matter
is iraq today is in worse condition than
when saddam hussein was there
and my question is the book has been out
its title is hoodwinked
the subject matter is there that's where
the evidence my question is
where is the american media
mr fund you want to take that
you know i um
i can barely answer questions about my
own book much less a book i haven't read
questions
well let let me respond to it please
make it brief and because the overall
sentiment is
uh
what did the american media do um in the
exception to the rulers on democracy now
every day
we
talked about what the evidence was and
that was absolutely critical now we're
starting to see some mia culpas in the
press the new york times had a box on
page 810 letter from the editor the
times in iraq where they started to go
through and said maybe they got it kind
of wrong i call it a kind of culpa and
it is not enough washington post a full
page piece on how they iced out dissent
as they look at it now well democracy
now was one of the few news outlets that
on a regular basis was bringing out the
voices of people inside and outside the
system in the intelligence community in
military who are saying no there aren't
weapons inspectors there aren't
there isn't the evidence of weapons of
mass destruction and that yet you had a
corporate media across the board that
week after week month after month front
page stories alleging weapons of mass
destruction and the only way they could
do that was simply acting as a megaphone
for those in power there was so much
accumulating evidence going in the other
direction i think that's why let me let
me let john fun because they've heard
from two people who are very much
opposed to it do you think that the bush
administration lied no
uh british intelligence thought they
were weapons of mass destruction french
military intelligence the french
military intelligence thought their
weapons of mass destruction all of the
members of the senate intelligence
committee thought they were weapons of
mass destruction john kerry thought
there were weapons of mass destruction
there were a whole bunch of people and
guess what
there may still have been weapons of
mass destruction they may have been
shipped over the border to syria
now
was the capability for weapons of mass
destruction there you betcha we know
that much
if you're arguing about whether or not
american intelligence failed as it
failed on 9 11 and i don't think nearly
enough people got fired for intelligence
failures either in iraq or after 9 11.
then that is a legitimate argument but
to automatically take that and ratchet
it up to people lied is to take the same
approach that people did
with franklin delaware roosevelt and
pearl harbor he must have known he must
have deceived us no government is far
more incompetent than it is venal far
more incompetent is venal and i think it
is a dangerous assumption to
automatically go into conspiracy
theories and to use terms like lying or
being dishonest when usually it's simply
a failure of information
i want to put up on the screen the
numbers for folks to call from home
there are the numbers those who support
president bush that's the
top of the line there and the next line
is senator kerry and then others who do
not plan to vote for either president
bush or senator kerry yes or your name
please william bindi uh i have a
question for mr fund but
first i wanted to support what he was
just saying about the
wmd going to syria our national
reconnaissance satellite saw
convoys of trucks going from iraq to
syria right before the war right before
the war
now here's a question for you
off of letterman's top ten list what
would be the top ten things other than
wmd iraq would be sending to syria just
before the war
there there's you know a lot of things
that i think cash to help them bury it
and make sure that no one else ever
found them yeah a lot of trucks were
going there and a lot of the
money the cash that the um uday and kusa
had was found in other places inside
iran uday and kusey spent three and a
half months in syria without anyone
knowing they were there that's before
they went back to be killed by the
americans if we didn't know sudai and
usa were in syria for three and a half
months an awful lot of things could have
gone across the border including an
awful lot of money to keep the syrians
quiet forever you have a question for mr
thing is a lot of
it was recently reported that
iraqi
agents went to help the
border guards on the border between
syria and iraq and that may have been
involved with the wmd movie now here's a
question for
john about
his book which is a subject i'm very
interested in stealing elections i was
wondering how he how much time he
talks about the or how much
he goes into the 1960 election because i
think that was one of the most imp
important
elections in that regard regarding
voter fraud
this is not an historical book there is
not a single anecdote or piece of
evidence here that is later than 1999 or
2000 it addresses the electronic voting
problems you know there are a lot of
people who worry about manchurian
computer programmers in the back rooms
that are going to alter the election
results uh if we have atm style voting
machines uh but there's also low-tech
voter fraud that is a lot of people
worry about a one-third of the country
is going to vote absentee that's
old-fashioned paper ballots
old-fashioned paper ballots are the
easiest way in the world to commit voter
fraud or voter chicanery so what we have
is a systemic system
systemic problem in which a whole bunch
of people are basically voting on the
honor system we register to vote in the
honor system two-thirds of the state do
not require photo identification to vote
we require photo identification to board
a plane to rent a video at blockbuster
but not to vote so all kinds of things
are possible and the real reason you
have to worry about this is if we have a
close election and the legitimacy of the
election is in doubt as it was with many
people in 2000 after florida i think the
very fabric of our democracy could be
affected and the voter turnout that amy
talks about is going to plummet even
further because if people don't believe
the election is legitimate or they don't
believe that the election was conducted
honestly and fairly and 44 percent of
americans worry about that right now the
next time we could see a voter turnout
fall way below 50 percent and then the
entire legitimacy of the system comes
into question amy goodman do you have uh
plans to support anybody for this
election uh i'm not
supporting people publicly i'm there to
cover what is going on and fairly give
voice to all of those who are running
and the people on the ground and what
they're doing in their communities when
you hear about this book about the
election how do you feel about is this
going to be a fair election oh i mean i
think that there are very grave concerns
i mean the fact
that as we move to the electronic voting
systems and the voting systems some of
these electronic voting machines uh the
companies that run them promising like
the ceo
of one of those companies promising that
he'll deliver the votes to bush um the
fighting's not what he said uh oh no he
he actually didn't it's sorry he said it
no i actually have a quote on the book i
can read it to you and in florida well
he is he is sorry that he said it and he
said that he wants you're not entitled
to your own facts but go ahead in
florida
the issue in congress right now the fact
that the republicans are stopping a bill
going forward that would give some kind
of receipt or record of how people vote
congressman holt's legislation the only
problem is that could not be implemented
by november whether it's worthy or not
there is no way you could implement it
by november who's the ceo of what
company that you have in your book that
you say didn't say what he said warden
odell
and and what company is it it's d bold
which is based out of columbus ohio and
what did he say what did you say how did
i get it wrong he wrote a fundraising
letter yes in which he was soliciting
funds for the rangers which is a
republican fundraising pack and which he
said and we all have to do all that we
can to deliver ohio's electoral votes to
to bush excuse me but excuse me excuse
me my main point where you're trying to
change that you said his company he
would do everything i didn't say his
company would deliver it i said he and
his company john just the facts okay
electronic voting black box voting the
software is new
uh the software often has bugs in it
there are problems
uh you can go on electionline.org which
is a great election resource and you can
find out all about those problems but
we have had the same electronic voting
systems in a slightly different form
with optical scan systems the same
centralized computers that can be
jiggered by hackers for 20 years there's
been no verified case of that happening
and i'm concerned when people who worry
about the electronic box box voting why
don't they have the same concern about
the same computers that count the
optical scan voting which more americans
will be using than the electronic atm
style machines they only worry about one
machine but frankly if they're worrying
about hackers they should worry about
also the optical scan systems that most
americans use the other point joe andrew
who was terry mcauliffe's predecessor as
democratic national committee chairman
he was chairman of the democratic
national committee during bill clinton's
second term he has said when it comes to
the issue of electronic voting the
internet conspiracy theorists on the
left he says are frankly bonkers because
they are manufacturing these incidents
out of thin air electronic voting once
the software bugs are worked out is
actually better for poor people better
for people with low education better for
people who have limited proficiency in
english better for older people better
for people with disabilities so
many problems yes and we have to be
concerned about them but if you're
talking about a grand conspiracy no
other no better authority figure than
the former chairman of the democratic
national committee says that stuff on
the that you read on the internet is
frankly just fanciful we need a call
from los angeles please on the other
coast go ahead please you're on the air
hello why are we talking about james
bamford's new book a pretext for war i'm
a conservative republican and i listen
to democracy now every day and it's one
of the best news programs out there and
mr fund you just work for the
neo-conservative wall street journal and
we see you hawking for more war for
israel how do you feel about path
buchanan's new book
where the right went wrong how
neo-conservatives most of whom are
racist jewish zionist extremists that
are willing to lose american lives for
israel to neutralize israel's enemies
how do you feel about his new book he
was on meet the press today i think your
right to free speech is a wonderful
thing amy goodman
first of all i condemn any kind of
bigotry um
i think that uh inch it is interesting
to look at a program like meet the press
this morning which i watched um when uh
the anti-war point of view and i see
this not only on tim russert's show but
just across the board whenever they're
going to bring on someone to represent
an anti-war point of view it's a
right-wing extremist like pat buchanan
there are many people progressive people
long-time peace activists who are
extremely credi credible represent large
movements of people who should be
represented um and i and i amy don't you
believe in a coalition pat buchanan
agrees with you on the war why don't you
make common cause with him i did not
criticize pat buchanan for being opposed
to war but i did say that when that the
media has got to start including the
point of view of nothing he represents
the anti-war points he is sincere about
it john i'm i'm trying to wonder if it's
that you really can understand what i'm
saying there is a sector of the
population in this country that is
completely iced out of the mainstream
dennis kucinich was under the press
twice pat buchanan dennis kucinich did
run for president i'm talking about
people who are working in their
communities leaders in their communities
whose views are almost not represented
you didn't respond to what i said the
four major nightly newscasts only three
with anti-war representatives i did i
didn't respond
why is the corporate media icing out
this view pat buchanan is entitled to
his view it's good and it should be
heard
but he is not the leader of the anti-war
movement in this country and to the
exclu if he is only interviewed to the
exclusion of others it is simply not
enough
let me repeat my point which is i said
earlier that there is a bias in the
media in favor of people in suits and in
favor of white males and there's a whole
bias against people who aren't elected
officials who don't have titles
so
the problem is
a bias not against a point of view a
bias against people who don't have an
elected position who don't have a fancy
title don't have a phd and teach in an
eastern school now
very few of those people in congress
opposed the war with the exception of
dennis kucinich and howard dean both of
which were who i meet the press several
times almost everyone else in the
democratic party ted kennedy accepted
went for the hills on the war so the
bias is
but you're saying i didn't address the
question i did but it's more class-based
and it's more suit-based than it is
ideological uh well there we would
disagree but i agree it oh i completely
agree it's class-based and i also would
agree it's racist i mean let's face it
oh wow
the overwhelming well how is it racist
look well let's look at this well i mean
you realize
jesse jackson appear on those shows all
the time you will often race barack
obama is now there all the time barack
obama and how much interesting he is
legitimate anti-war candidate
very interesting you raised barack obama
a very important figure rising star in
the democratic party he spoke he was the
keynote speaker on tuesday night at the
democratic national convention the night
that the corporate networks almost gave
no coverage now um uh
there is it's interesting that we
interviewed um jimmy breslin the
pulitzer prize-winning reporter up at
the democratic national convention and
asked what he thought about coverage he
said his first comment well as what he
thought about the connection is the
media should have their licenses pulled
for what they have done or haven't done
that they have cut back on their
coverage of the conventions and what
that means is that there was only this
small window of people who would be
heard i mean the democratic republican
parties understood this too and they
didn't put barack obama in prime
minister if the networks had given every
hour of the convention coverage
do you really think the ratings would
have gone up
not really they wouldn't have 83 percent
of america has cable 100 of america's
access to public television anyone who
wanted to watch the convention all the
way through could as long as they had a
television the answer is not just about
whether you give three hours or a
hundred hours it's also the kind of
coverage that's given first of all you
can give something in between but also
the kind of coverage it's not just about
covering the podium i was on the floor
of the democratic national convention
and the republican national convention
the democratic national convention those
delegates more than 4 000 of them
overwhelmingly anti-war overwhelmingly
anti-usa patriot act you did not hear
this message from the podium in fact
those who carried signs or war pink back
down just once
not with the media
here i am yes that's true right now
that's true but no it's two prong with
the democratic party they iced out
dissent they would confiscate signs and
bandanas that they thought were off
message it surprised many delegates who
thought they were on message so you have
the democratic party yes icing out
dissent but it didn't take many steps
for those 15 000 reporters covering four
thousand delegates to walk onto the
convention floor and report this story
and talk about the difference in message
that's what's called a little i went on
the convention floor at the fleet center
and i did talk to a whole bunch of
delegates and they were very circumspect
not just with me but with a whole bunch
of reporters because they had been told
don't talk about what you want to talk
about talk about the party so there was
a group thing well if you
i am furious that this party is icing
out anti-war descent and i think we
should storm the podium you can't report
that if they don't say it and they don't
want to say it because they're being the
party
about simply the polls the girls of the
delegates indicated that they
overwhelmed those those are secret polls
they don't have to give their name let
me go to the audience
didn't take much they wouldn't talk to
me and they wouldn't talk to my
colleagues at the journal would you
please give us your name my name is
elsie francis and
i'm probably old enough to be
your mother and your mother thank you
what about me
i've seen you around a long time
john
john
take your own advice perhaps about
your own facts
i'm
just amazed at the time and energy
that's being wasted in this country and
this world
on things like homosexuality
and abortion
when people are dying in this country
and all over the world because they
don't have medicine for the common cold
and worms
not to just leave out aids
and i want to know when will the media
start addressing the important things
when will the media start telling the
truth will we ever know the truth about
things
that
happened within the past 200 years or
are we going to have to wait
another 200 years to know the truth of
what is going on now when you say media
can you define that
the media that will not deal with
whatever doesn't get the proper
ratings
the media that
doesn't deal with whatever will not sell
the most newspapers and magazines
the media that does not want to deal
with anything that they are afraid of
will
take away
their money
their high salaries
the media that is afraid of whoever is
in power at the time can i ask you this
question would you
with today's internet and all the
different publications the things you're
talking about are discussed somewhere
they're discussed by those who look for
it they are talking to
they are talking to the people who agree
with them they're talking to
those people who
and please leave your finger down for
now
they're talking to the people
who already are interested
there are
millions of people all over the world
and i i always hesitate to say in this
country
because this country
is affected by what happens in every
other country and every other country
is affected by what happens in this
country so i say
there are billions of people in the
world who do not know what is going on
who have no idea
that even their neighbors down the
street might have aids who have no idea
that the baby across the street is dying
from worms in this day and age okay
let's let john fund react to your
comments
one of the easiest things to do
is
to complain about all of the information
that people should seek out and should
want but they don't
and
i'll be honest with you when you're an
adult it's very hard to change your
habits whether they're good or bad
you're basically formed and this
information sources you seek out the
level of curiosity you have is pretty
much there
i think we would all be better off if we
look to the next generation
and the next generation is not being
served well by the appalling state of
our public school system especially in
the urban areas
we have
a large number of people who grow up
able to read but not interested in
reading not interested in seeking out
any information other than pop culture
or entertainment now
many of them
aren't particularly interested in doing
that no matter how good the public
education system is but we can do a
whole lot better job if you want to
expand the ability of people to process
information and their curiosity level we
have to have radical reform of our urban
public education system and i think a
fundamental component of that is the
kind of thing that uh
various various recent mayors of new
york and chancellor klein have supported
which are charter schools and various
components of choice in education and
that would be a whole lot better in
order to get these people interested in
subjects we have destroyed civics
education this country history has
either been completely ignored has been
turned over public to the politically
correct forces and ultimately become
meaningless in its instruction so if you
want to improve people's interest in
these sensitive subjects like aids both
of africa and in america you're gonna
have to improve the education system and
hope for the next generation will have a
greater level of curiosity
hold your thought just a second i want
to get this call from queens it's our
last call then i'll come right back to
you queens what what's on your mind
yes i'm concerned with the
fourth estate becoming a fifth column
for the conservatives
um
it seems that the republicans are being
given a free pass that they are the
people who can protect us from terrorism
now the last time i looked mr clinton
and i wish him well
our president the last one elected by
all the people and re-elected with no
question
send cruise missiles into afghanistan
into the al qaeda training camps
the republicans and their fellow
travelers
chose to talk about wag the dog and get
back on his unfortunate infidelities all
right caller thanks uh amy goodman you
we're well we only have about three
minutes right well first i'll respond to
uh the
john fund saying that we should now go
more put more money into charter schools
the latest study done showing that
charter schools are just a massive
failure and that should get a lot more
attention i very much appreciate
the woman who just spoke and talked
about the crisis at home in this country
we've got billions of dollars going to
iraq and we have a crisis in this
country
tens of millions of people who don't
have health care
we have uh impoverished education the
answer is pouring could you imagine if
instead of invading iraq uh the u.s put
the sa the bush administration put that
money into the schools of this country
true public education for everyone i
think that would increase national
security and health care more than
anything that they have done and what
they did by invading iraq is simply
increasing uh national insecurity um and
it's not even saying sending billions of
dollars to iraq because we know that is
not where the money is going the money
is simply going to these massive
corporations connected to the bush
administration like halliburton cheney
still receiving a check from halliburton
that is bankrupting this country and we
do have to turn it all around and we
need a media that honestly reflects what
is happening on the ground not what john
believes america looks like but what
america really does look like i agree
with his class analysis but i also think
we have to look at every aspect of a
fiercely ideological media yes fox
doesn't reach that many people
but it is definitely
paving the way the media for some reason
following in their footsteps and i would
say that cnn abc and cbs the rest and i
exclude c-span because i do also want to
say
the sp c-span has been so important in
opening up the debate
but we have to both critique and condemn
and
continue to hold the corporate media
accountable but we have to shore up
independent media and let people know
where they can go for independent
information i really do think that is
the hope um for this country we need an
independent media serving a democratic
society we've been at the strand all
afternoon since noon thanks to nancy
bass who's sitting right back there and
her father fred who's all the way in the
back for being so hospitable
and and to wrap it up we have one last
comment from our guest at the microphone
what would you like to say i'm curious
to know why there hasn't been more
coverage about the lat the speech that
president
bush made the night of the inauguration
where he said
uh the world the united the amer america
is a safer country and he has made the
whole world safer i can't imagine how
he'd think so he's made the whole world
safer when every single day there's
another place that's being bombed where
more people are being sent from these um
these countries that are
against what we're doing and i don't
understand how he takes the arrogance of
saying that he's made us safer i don't
see that how he has thanks very much we
have
15 seconds john fun comment the world
was made unsafe on 9 11 by people who
wanted to do us harm that is why the
world is unsafer and i was there at the
world trade center i saw everything that
happened that day and i have to tell you
we have to prosecute this war on
terrorism because weakness and lack of
resolve is precisely what the enemies of
freedom democracy and diversity want 15
seconds amy goodman and president bush
has compounded the insecurity and i
think people in this country are looking
for an alternative that john kerry has
yet to represent people should check out
democracynow.org a daily thorough
investigative unembedded news source in
this country for people here and around
the world
again we are now totally out of time and
we thank you very much and have a good
evening
[Applause]
oh
so
for more information on the strand
bookstore visit strandbooks.com
next month on in-depth angela davis the
longtime activist and history professor
will consider her complete body of work
including angela davis on autobiography
women race in class blues legacies and
black feminism and our prisons obsolete
in depth with angela davis is live
sunday october 3rd at noon eastern on
book tv
[Music]